We're live.
My just like that seems like there should be some sort of a like a chime.
We ring
DME.
It's the
big goal.
Five footer,
not a big gong.
Big Gowns are obnoxious cause then you're just going to talk,
be a big gun.
If you're going to have like a fucking Cirque de Solei experience and bunch of
dudes come out flipping with fire and do fucking juggle flames or [inaudible] a
good Kuma Tanium so good.
Kuma Tay Bot,
Dr Dan,
you've got a notebook over there dude,
when you go,
what are you going on here?
Well I saw you guys with all these note pads so he just wanted to make sure that
what's going on man.
But 27 years of school I get used to taking notes.
Dr Dan Angle here with the Obgyn.
Motherfucking Marco's in the house and we started to sit down and talk.
Shoot the shit we just got done doing 200 and some fucking degrees below zero
cryo therapy sessions your first time ever in the full body one head immersion.
Yeah,
it's the real one,
right?
Real deal.
Yeah.
You can only get,
those are a couple of places right now.
That's,
that's ultimately going to be what it is.
It's going to be the difference being the other ones they pour,
it's like nitrogen all over your skin,
like a frozen nitrogen sort of thing.
But you can't breathe it.
That's why your head is above.
But this,
what they do is they freeze the air instead and you go in there and it's just
fucking ungodly,
insanely cold and you wear a mouth like a surgeon's mask over your face and
earmuffs and gloves and those rubber.
It's the only time we usually allowed to wear rubber crocs.
Those crock clog things and not feel like an asshole.
But um,
what'd you experience with that?
You know,
I think for me a key part is getting that upper half of my body in the,
in the tank,
you know,
we haven't wanted on it.
That's awesome.
For any kind of inflammation in my legs,
my knees,
my,
you know,
my hips is really good.
But then getting that like,
so it's cold is getting into your eye sockets and the cold's getting into your,
the temples of your head.
If I find it really relaxing,
actually a lot of people think it gives a lot of energy.
I found I like deeply relaxing.
After you got out you were really relaxed.
That's interesting.
Yeah.
Everybody seems to have a different reaction to it.
Robin was talking about that after it was over,
he was saying that some people feel like uh,
an endorphin crash at the end of the day.
Like you have this big rush when you get out of there and the end of the day
you're very tired,
which I found really weird cause I don't get that at all.
I get out of there and I'm like,
dude,
I feel fucking great.
I'm addicted to that thing.
Yeah,
I bet your first time doing it ever.
Or have you done this time?
You have you done the one that they have it on it?
Nope.
Today was my debut.
What'd you guys do?
Two and a half minutes.
Like pussies.
So what happened?
I mean to and do the whole three hours at least
a log time.
Yeah.
It's,
um,
three minutes in,
a few minutes out and then three minutes back in.
It's a great way to start the day.
It's a very addictive though.
If you had one near your house,
man,
you get addicted.
It's more addictive than the one with your head above it for whatever reason.
Cause there's something about like,
you survive it,
you know?
And like there's like this weird,
like once you get out of there,
it's like,
yes,
I'm back.
Yes,
yes,
yes.
You know,
you started fucking hot foot and around the room.
Ooh.
You know,
it just,
you feel like you survived and you want to go back and do it again.
Yeah.
There's a crucible element to it.
Whereas this is something I accomplished for sure.
I feel that we just get out of it.
Dan.
Yeah.
I watched my system go into the survival mode.
Like that last minute.
Why does a doctor like it must have been interesting knowing the functions of
the body intimately.
Yeah.
I'm always curious about,
uh,
health recovery,
the crucible experience,
putting ourselves in these really extreme situations.
Um,
and then that last minute,
the first one was pretty much a piece of cake.
The second one I was cold straight off and in that last minute I went into these
involuntary shakes and I'm watching my body just jump around like a little race
car inside.
I'm like,
oof,
maybe I can just work on tune in this down a little bit.
And I'm like,
cause then in jobbing doing whatever I,
Jimi Hendrix was playing in the background,
um,
and nothing was working and it was just like hyper drive.
So I'm just watching this thing going like trippy.
So this is like significant mind body separation.
I had no control over that experience.
So as far as being put in the crucible,
like this survival experience,
like when I came out that I definitely felt like I had crossed some kind of
threshold of an experience that I wouldn't have had other,
yeah.
Have you ever done the ice bath?
You know those,
those things we climb into the thing of it's filled with ice and water and
they've on that one.
Yeah.
Those are miserable.
More miserable.
Right.
I think they're more miserable.
Yeah.
Cause your toes get to another level of frozen frozen as well.
It's a wet just soaks window gets deep into your bones.
Yeah.
It feels good though too.
You pop out of that,
you actually feel warmer.
I think when you come out of that for some real,
there's like a numbness that happens that makes you feel weirdly warm.
Whereas the Cryo you still feel a little cold when you,
have you ever gone in the Pacific Ocean in like January?
I used to live out here.
Yeah.
We'd go out there.
That's chilly.
But you know that feeling like you really shouldn't be warm when you get outside
because it's only like 70 degrees outside,
but you're like,
ah,
air that's 70 feels so good.
Yeah,
totally.
There's something about,
we were discussing this about forcing the body to react to a,
the sauna doctor Rhonda Patrick who wrote that really,
um,
really fascinating paper on the effects of thought of Sauna and she's a huge
proponent of sauna and the reaction that your body has to this extreme heat of
the sauna so your body compensates in some way for that.
And then when it realizes it's just temporary situation,
you get the benefit of that compensation without actually being in some life
threatening position where your body has to,
you know,
fire up all these protection systems.
Yeah.
All kinds of things going on and you got creation in the heat shock proteins.
You've got all of these biochemical processes going on.
Plus just that general thing that the body needs,
body needs resistance,
you know,
it needs,
germs when you're a kid.
It needs to squeeze through the vaginal canal and pick up all the Goo when
you're young to get a climatize.
It needs,
you know,
workouts when you're old and,
and bigger things to stress the muscles and these things to stress the system
all the way across the board.
It's just the way humans are built.
We're not built for a cakewalk.
Yeah.
Bird built to deal with whatever the fuck we have to deal with.
And if you make your body deal with almost nothing,
what you get is like a spoiled child.
Right.
That can't handle any sort of,
you know,
any,
any negative or any,
any conflict,
any,
any problems,
anything that's offline.
We're requires character or resolve.
Yeah.
Like you meet those people who grew up in the wilderness and they're like,
they can eat more foods and you can,
they can,
they don't get sick as often.
They're just more resilient.
You know,
like my friend Bodie,
you grew up in New Hampshire,
you know,
it's like what he can put his body through from just growing up on a farm with
no running water and hardly any electricity and just kind of cruising around
from a young age,
climbing mountains and skiing down even when he was freezing.
Like he can deal with shit in a different way than someone who's just been,
put your coat on sweetie.
Make sure your scarf is all tied up.
You know,
it was like a different level of savagery that has actually allowed him to train
harder for his sport and you know,
be better because his body was used to dealing with tough shit from an early
age.
Yeah.
That's uh,
it's fascinating because people,
and uh,
you know,
I'm guilty of it.
We want to protect our children from adversity.
Yeah.
But adversities would,
builds character.
So it's like,
you know,
you want your kids to be safe for,
the only way to make them safe is to put them in danger.
Right.
Everybody that I know that will be fine.
They're all dude's who've gone through some horrific shit.
And their life,
you know,
I know I'll leave that dude will,
he'll be fine.
Right,
right.
Well,
the people that can handle it,
the one that'll,
the ones that will fall apart,
they're the ones who their mom wiped their ass until they're 11 years old.
Fucked,
fucked.
It doesn't work.
Humans are just a flawed thing.
Well,
I mean,
we're kind of designed in that sort of weird way.
We're designed for this savage world.
I mean,
this world is not,
it's beautiful and I love it,
but it's not easy and it was never intended to be easy,
you know?
And so we're designed to have to learn from these and get stronger because of
our environment.
We separate ourselves from the environment.
The human ceases to be what it was originally designed to be,
which is a being that reacts to the pressures of its environment.
You isolate it and then we don't have that resistance anymore and we turn out
like a blob.
Well,
there was a study that I tweeted yesterday about that,
um,
sort of a indirect relation to that about young men today that are addicted to
pornography and video games.
And they,
they're going through this masculinity crisis.
So it was this a psychological breakdown of young men in our society today
because they're not going through any real adversity.
They're not going through any real rites of passage pushing themselves,
physically know what they're doing is they're just beating off and playing video
games.
Take this weird world that they live in,
whether it's kind of like they're symbiotic relationship with a couch and an
Xbox controller.
Right?
Yeah.
What do you,
what do you think's going to happen with that?
What are the downstream effects?
Their doctor Dan?
Yeah.
I think they're seeing that study.
I haven't seen this study you're talking about,
but that makes perfect sense.
Um,
we're having like two divergent populations where some people are,
are really seeking these kinds of experiences where they're able to stress their
system,
grow that,
grow their potential,
become their best selves.
And you have another people that because they don't have a connection to what's
happening,
then I have a connection to purpose,
passion,
drive inspiration.
They're not mentored.
They're not going through these rites of passage.
They're not going through any kind of,
um,
uh,
supportive exploration of themselves in the world.
They're just finding ways to distract themselves and,
and find some kind of pleasure in the craziness of it all.
So in the midst of that,
you're going to have this,
uh,
this massive widening between these two divergent populations.
It's so seductive
on the video game though,
because you think you're improving yourself because you have these characters
that are,
that are avatars that are you to an actual real population of people who
identify you as that character.
And then the more work you put into that character,
the more you improve it.
It improves their skills,
they get richer,
they get bad ass shit,
like the equivalent of rims that spin on their weapons,
and then they get level 40,
50,
60,
and then you're really swinging a big dick out there.
You know,
when you're that big.
So it's this seductive thing of they do feel like they're improving,
but they're not actually.
Yeah.
How do you actualize that in the world?
Well,
is it,
is that the case or was it this,
are we in some sort of a transitionary period between a physical,
biological,
carbon base,
cellular life,
and a digital life?
Because once,
if we really do transition to a digital life,
which there's a lot of speculation from legitimate scientists and people that
are looking at the curve of learning and the exponential growth of technology
and they're like,
look,
this is inevitable.
We're not going to be physical beings for much longer.
Like it's pretty,
it's pretty obvious that we're going to eventually incorporate with machines and
to the point where the,
the concept of living in a virtual world,
a world where you can just put on these headsets and go into the world of Avatar
and live out this intense,
unbelievably rich existence inside this artificially created world is going to
be so much more appealing and attractive.
And that's,
I think that's what we're seeing with these kids when they're playing call of
duty or in these other games.
It's so much better than going out and being a regular teenager with no job
prospects,
no skills,
no nothing unique about you,
nothing particularly challenging in your life other than,
you know,
feeding yourself and getting to bed on time.
You know,
it's just nothing there.
But they can go into this world and this fucking bullets flying overhead and
they're all talking on headsets and trying to set up an ambush to go get the
enemy and that,
that,
that the helicopters are flying overhead and that's way more exciting.
It's way more exciting.
And this is just the beginnings of this,
this,
this digital world.
I mean there's,
these are artificial realities that they exist in,
but there's so clearly artificial that we don't think of him that way.
We think of him as a video game,
but once it becomes something that's indistinguishable once we had something
going on inside your head,
I mean,
how many years are we really away from something where you put it on and it has
electrodes that react with various,
various areas in your brain where they can stimulate these areas and reproduce
insane visual effects,
physical effects that the feeling of your foot on gravel as you're running down
this beach.
Like you feel it in your feet.
I mean,
how long before they can do that?
It's not that far off.
It's way closer than going to another planet.
It's way closer than,
you know,
setting up a colony on the moon pretty fucking close to doing this.
This is a decade away at most.
It's a kind of a weird,
exciting,
but terrifying thought.
Very terrifying.
You know?
I mean you,
you want to thank,
you want to hold out and think,
ah,
the real world will be better.
I know it,
they won't get the smells right,
but like they're little still screwed something up,
you know?
But it's very possible that eventually they can create virtual worlds that will
be pretty satisfying.
But I dunno,
I just,
I want to hold out faith.
Maybe it's just a desire of the romantic desire.
I want to hold out faith that doing something for reals,
for reals,
you know,
feeling your real body underneath you.
Or maybe it's just even the knowledge that it's for reals,
for reals.
It just seems like that would be better,
you know?
Yeah.
For now.
But if it keep continues to improve and grow,
it's,
it's seems like it's gonna
be like way more satisfying live that you're talking about the matrix.
Right.
So then it really depends on who's the puppet master [inaudible] and what the
agenda is to make ms creating the matrix.
Yeah.
And for what outcome or what reason?
It could the matrix be something that the user career,
it's,
I mean,
could it be autonomous?
Could it,
could the user decide what kind of experience and then what you just going to be
the king of the Matrix.
You just going to be gangas con fucking all these women and cutting everybody's
heads off.
And never lose a war.
I mean is that,
what are we going to do,
Ellen?
It's kind of talks about that like when you get total control of something it
becomes boring and so then you then you would want to naturally add in elements
of risk,
add in elements of uncertainty because then it becomes exciting again.
So actually probably the progression will be,
if you listen to that Allen Watson ception video,
the progression will be,
you know you go in and you do that.
You get to be gang is con you have sex with 100,000 women,
you rate all these places,
you win everything and then all of a sudden you make it more difficult so you
don't know if you're going to win and then to make it exciting,
you don't know if you're going to get laid again and then all of a sudden you
reprogram it back and realize,
holy shit,
life was life was what I really wanted all along.
It has all the uncertainty and challenge that makes this thing really fun,
otherwise it's all fucking boring.
Or
we find out that life itself is actually just a virtual reality and that we've
all this time been living in this incredibly realistic simulation.
Cool.
I'll give the program or a high five because this shit's awesome.
Pretty good.
They did a good job.
That means they set up all the preposterous aspects that make you question it's
reality,
right?
Like,
um,
the Chris Christie thing we were talking about today was in the news that he's,
he spent some fucking ungodly amount of money.
The,
you know,
if you don't know who Chris Christie is,
he's the,
he's the governor of New Jersey and he's an enormously morbidly overweight
gentleman who wants to run for president and also wants to make sure that people
don't smoke marijuana because marijuana is bad for you,
unlike massively overeating,
which apparently is not that bad for you.
But,
uh,
this is,
this was the B.
It's this,
it seems like it's not real.
When you read this,
he spent $82,000 of tax payer money on food at NFL Games.
You know how much food costs it and it felt games.
Not much.
It's like $8 for a sausage.
How much she has to eat.
It's insane how much money he spent,
but this is all taxpayer money.
This is why it's so fucked up,
man.
God,
it's insane.
It's hard to believe.
You know one thing that they will never get right in one of these experiences
though is like the true mystical experience.
You know,
in this virtual reality world,
going to sit,
drink iowasca
virtually is not going to be the same as sitting down hearing the eco rose,
the sound and the jungle and drinking that in reality,
like that dimension is so different than what I think could ever be program.
So at least I think we got that one.
We can hold out for me.
Well,
that was what Mckenna believed they were going to be able to,
they,
he believed that the DMT experience was going to be accessible to people,
to virtual reality.
First.
He said that most people are not going to be willing to take the leap of faith
that it takes to light the DMT and take it into your lungs and visit the spirit
realm.
And he really thought that the way they were going to create it was someone was
going to figure out how to make a virtual reality version of a DMT experience.
And that was what,
and he thought that if you did do that,
you would actually contact the real DMT realm and you actually,
they would be a way that they would enter through that gate.
Well,
obviously he did wait to me.
He went too far.
I kind of went too far,
was on brother.
I mean he was amazing.
He was an amazing bard and he had some incredible ideas because of that.
But that was one of the big ones.
You can duplicate the,
the visuals,
but the creativity and the specificity of what the messages that come across,
I mean it's not just random,
it doesn't work for everybody.
It's not like picking up a,
you know,
an astrology book where it,
it kind of work for most people or whatever.
You know,
it's,
this is specific information for you that comes out,
you know,
and I think that that true connection with whatever that other place in your
brain is or that other world,
you know,
the astro world,
whatever you want to call it,
your vocabulary permits that that true access allows this kind of really unique
message to come through that's just tailored for you.
And that's why it's so effective.
Yeah.
That is one of the weird and unique aspects of psychedelic experiences.
It's almost like what you need at that time finds you,
it's like you like almost like there's an assessment of your overall predicament
and go,
oh look this,
why these things keep going on Jim,
to show you guys,
show us what,
oh,
that's okay.
Don't worry about it.
Um,
Goddamn Tri caster,
shitty fucking machine.
Um,
but it seems like they,
it,
it finds whatever,
whatever hole you've got and then fills it in like,
oh,
you just shove this in that hole and now you're going to get a,
a sense of what's wrong and you're going to get a sort of a depiction or a
picture of what the errors on your operating system are.
Yup.
That finds it.
Is that what you think it makes psychedelic research so appealing?
Is that it's tailoring,
like dialing in a specific solution for each individual
from a psyche psychiatric standpoint then?
Yeah,
I think there are a couple of different opportunities that it presents,
which is bringing up to the surface that very thing that we're ready to receive
that we didn't realize it was right there.
And it also helps to rewrite the neurochemistry and reboot the neuroendocrine
system to let you actualize it and move it forward into your life.
So the,
the psychedelics right now that the whole resurgence of psychedelic research is,
is showing how well they work for the very aspects that psychiatry is really
weak at.
Addiction recovery,
treatment resistant depression,
chronic severe PTSD,
end of life transition issues,
all the areas that psychiatry is really stuck at,
the psychedelics are,
are very good at and there's a wide breadth of the psychedelics that are
available and then we get really crafty and being able to,
to recognize because of what this person is going through,
what might be the best psychedelic to use for them in the right setting.
So in the right set and setting,
you get this opportunity to really actualize your best self to realize what you
weren't looking at and to face your shit to work through that and then to see
the path of becoming even better.
That's a,
those are really good points.
The,
the,
the drug addiction one is really good point.
The end of life transition as another really good point.
And Ptsd even,
you know,
traumatic stress,
I mean he could be as horrific as war or as seemingly simple but unbelievably
traumatic as a breakup.
You know,
there's some people that go through breakups and they think their fucking life
is over.
They think it's over.
I mean they think like,
I can't go on like this.
Like this loss is too much for my soul to bear.
And then they do ecstasy and they go,
oh,
I'm going to be fine.
Thanks guys.
An asshole.
Why?
Why was it even living with him in the first place?
Oh,
she was ruining my life.
I didn't even realize she was running my life.
Oh my God,
I'm just like a bitch because a bitch clinging to this fucking ridiculous idea
that this woman is going to save me or this man is going to save me.
Yeah.
We were talking just the other day about the,
the,
the prevalence of suicide and young teenage girls in certain communities,
particularly in native cultures.
Um,
and there's studies that show that young adolescents,
both girls and boys,
but particularly with girls,
they have a significant resolution of anxiety that's related to how they view
themselves going through only one session of Iowasca.
Wow.
That's incredible,
man.
Wow.
So that's really a new bridge that we're talking about like rights of passage,
those ceremonies,
those experiences really helped people mature,
self actualize,
be able to recognize who they really and not have so
much that's invested in and who they think they need to be in these
relationships that when they fall away like,
like this,
this crazy thing that happens with a internet bullying online and it just really
shatters these young people self esteem and they ended up like checking out like
that's too much.
That just completely collapsed their worldview and there's no idea that they can
not imagine themselves going through that in a successful way.
So it's better to check out.
They also can't imagine that this bullying,
as horrible as it is,
if you get through it and and you,
you gain perspective,
it'll actually help you later in life.
Like you will now have tools to deal with shitty human beings that you may
perhaps run into and he counterintuitively,
you will greatly appreciate the kind people around you in a way that you might
not appreciate them.
It's like people in La don't appreciate the sun,
right pitches there every day.
Cause nagging.
You got to put on your sunglasses,
you know,
but go to Seattle or go to go to fucking Columbus,
Ohio in the winter where every day is cloudy gray,
that gray sky winter thing,
the buffalo winter have been to buffalo,
New York.
I mean if it's the winter and you don't get any clouds,
you're like,
what is happening?
Look at the sky.
It's blue.
It's opposed to be blow.
But you just get used to that shit.
And when you do see the sun,
it's a magical creature that's come down to give you half
been asked in the form of vitamin D and warm,
warm feels like love.
Yeah.
The way it feels on your skin.
We're used to that.
Like,
oh my God,
it's so hot.
You know?
We're used to that here.
We've been so effective at taking away all of the really challenging things and
expecting not to have challenging things that I think it's going to take
intention to intentionally put those back through rituals,
through rites of passage,
through these terrifying scary or deals that you have to go through in order to
get used to that paradigm again.
You know,
I mean that's,
I think we're getting to the point now where we're so good at removing the
environmental ones.
We're going to have to go with intention to put them back.
And even back in scary times,
they had intentions to do that.
You go to some tribes who live in the jungle,
which is a hard ass place to live and they're still sticking their hands and
oven mitts of bullet ants are still fashioning bungee cords out of vines and
moldy ropes and stuff and jumping off towers,
you know,
to show that their show,
their fearlessness.
And even in our day we have everything easy.
So we have nothing environmental and we're not doing anything else intentional.
Yeah.
And this is definitely not to them to imply
that pulling isn't in any way.
Good.
No,
you know,
it's awful.
People that are mean.
I don't,
I,
I always wonder what that is when you see like kids that are shitty to other
kids,
you know,
like you see that like the instinct that they have to be shitty or they see
weakness and they poke at it and I push it,
it's not good.
But even in bad things,
the,
the counter to those bad things,
you can somehow or another get benefit from it and that benefit will make you
stronger.
And that's,
it's really fascinating.
Like what we were talking about,
the sauna or what we were talking about going through adversity in life,
like all of these things,
he seemed,
it seems to be almost a law that the universe has,
that the ebb and flow of things,
the push and the pull of things.
I mean,
I don't think it's a fucking,
I don't think it's a coincidence that these bad motherfuckers keep coming out of
Siberia,
you know?
I mean,
look at all these rue salon providing a cough,
you know,
um,
these,
these boxers that are coming out of the Soviet Union now and especially Siberia,
like they're fucking monsters.
You know?
Kovalev these guys are monsters and they're coming out of Russia.
It's cold as shit,
Russia.
So you develop a different kind of human being because they're,
they,
they're surviving all the time and in surviving they're
growing.
One of the traditions they're in Siberia is to go swim in the river.
And a lot of places they go swim in the river every morning.
Like in military cadet training.
Historically,
like the Siberian,
you know,
cadets would have to go in and jump in this freezing ass water every morning to
help toughen him up.
I mean,
they got that idea there and that's the healthy way to do it.
Obviously bullying is this really insidious kind of see,
you know,
psychological attack.
That's really hard to see and really hard to look at as a stress like that.
But yeah,
I mean,
building those things in your life,
it's going to make it,
it's going to be positive.
And that's what sports do for us.
Like sports or really sports in the military are really the only way that we
have access to these really readily here.
And I kind of think that for bullies,
even the act of bullying is extremely damaging just to do it.
I mean it only makes sense that it is right,
but you are causing all these bad feelings for all these people that don't
deserve it.
They didn't do anything to you and you're just finding a weakness or finding a
deficit in their strength and attacking it while you're doing it to yourself.
You know,
in the truth,
you know,
as,
as the platinum rule would say,
you're really doing it to you living a different life and that's really
difficult for the higher self,
you know,
the,
the conscious self to deal with because you're hurting herself in a very real
way.
Yeah.
You don't appreciate yourself,
you know,
you don't appreciate who you are because you don't respect it.
Cause you know,
you're kind of a bitch fucking with people that don't deserve it.
But you know,
it's,
it's just,
it's weird.
It's a weird instinct that children have cause a,
having children in wa seeing it,
like seeing it on the playground,
like seeing,
watching little boys push other little boys for no reason when watching how it
goes down.
It's very bizarre behavior.
And I,
and I,
I'm,
I've been struggling with recently not struggling with it or analyzing it as a
better sense,
trying to figure out when I do see it,
like what is,
what's the,
is there an evolutionary advantage to any of this?
Is there a reason why this exists or is this just from the harsh days of old
where you're just trying to find the weak wolf and kick it the fuck out of the
clan?
Because if you don't,
you know,
the pack won't be strong.
You got to get rid of all the bitches.
Do you cower when I come near you?
Are you cowering you fucking fat?
Fuck Outta here.
He kicked him out of the Goddamn tribe and send them out into the woods to die
on their own.
You know?
And I think there's,
it's awful.
But I got to think that's why wolves do it.
You know?
And Wolves sense like some wolf that's gonna fall apart under pressure.
Like you fucking pussy.
They go,
we can't hunt Moose with you.
You know you're going to,
you're going to get tired.
You Bitch,
you don't get the fuck out of here.
And that's exactly why humans have had these rituals before.
You know,
these different rites of passage will they,
will this person buckle under pressure?
You know,
they fold when it comes to her and it's like that person you walk up to on a
water slide and you wait in line for a goddamn hour with them and then they get
to the top of the water slide.
I can't do it.
Let me down.
You're like,
you gotta be fucking kidding.
I waited an hour to go down this thing and I'm not even excited about it.
You know,
like that person,
you got to weed that out early because what if you're on a,
you know,
a life and death situation.
They needed to know that if Dunkin was here right now you're talking about me,
man.
Stop talking about me.
I'm right here.
Yeah,
I mean that's,
and that was,
that was the old way and I think that's what we got to bring back,
but we can't do it in these like anonymous Facebook,
bullying,
cyber,
it's too complicated a stress for the human brain to to handle because we're not
equipped evolutionarily to handle that kind of stress.
I think we should call each other to their,
to courage and call each other to face these different things,
but not in that way.
Not in a mean way.
Not in a way like come on,
let's,
let's go,
let's see what we can do together here.
Do it in a different way.
Yeah.
The other thing about the,
the idea of the cyber world,
the idea of virtual worlds is that the people that are playing,
you know,
fill in the blank halo or,
and these crazy games getting really good at it,
they're not experiencing the character development that someone would have if
they got really good at,
you know,
whatever Jujitsu or you know,
fill in the blank,
may something incredibly difficult.
You know where you,
you see like when you meet someone who's really truly great at something,
anything where they put incredible amount of hard work and out of that hard work
has emerged is truly unique talent that something,
is that something fascinating to watch?
Like there's a quality to those people have that you don't get from cyber game
players and that's weird.
I wonder what that is because it's obviously difficult to get really good at
playing a video game.
It's obviously there's something rewarding about it because they love to do it.
They love to kick other people's asses and those video games.
But I don't necessarily think it translates into that character development in
the real world.
Like as in a personality sense.
And in fact there's like a lot,
I mean the,
when you talk about like people that are like cyber game players,
one of the big characterizations,
whether it's fair or not,
is that they're really awkward Dorks,
right?
Like that's the number one way you think of like someone who plays video games
all day.
Oh Jesus Christ.
What's his guy like to hang out with when,
you know,
get them outside,
and that's,
you know,
you're seeing a different type of player now.
Like I know,
you know,
some people we've worked with,
they'll do yoga and they'll like try to focus on that.
So you're starting to see a different type of that.
But I do agree for sure with your initial point.
And I think that the idea is that,
you know,
real consciousness is,
it's home is in the body.
And when people think of like mind and consciousness and body as all separate,
really,
when you're truly conscious,
it's when everything is like sucked into,
into one entity.
It's a true presence of being where you're physically embodying your
consciousness and when you're just using your mind and your thumbs,
it's almost like a,
you're separating yourself from a key element of consciousness,
which is embodied consciousness.
So you're working on a level of mastery that's really very narrow,
you know,
it's a good point.
That's a really good point.
That must be what it is,
right?
Well what it must be is like you're neglecting your body because you're sitting
on a couch all day and your fucking back is hunched at the end of the day.
I mean,
how many video game players have fucking horrible backs.
It's gotta be a lot,
right?
If you're playing all day,
hunched over a computer,
you're going blind and your back is turned to shit going blind from the
masturbation because that got to find that.
I do.
That's what I hear.
Yeah.
That's what Kellogg would tell us.
Did you ever deal with anybody,
I mean I know you worked with the people that have addiction.
Have you ever worked with people that have like non non chemical addictions or
non chemical in the traditional sense like like video game addictions or
gambling addictions?
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
I'm affiliated with the organization called crossroads and that's an Ibogaine
treatment center and we're also building the first psychedelic research
institute there.
Um,
when people go through Ibogaine it rewrites the neurochemistry reboots that
whole pathway and that pathway is set up for an addictive profile,
doesn't,
it?
Doesn't matter what the addiction is,
it's the same chemical pathway and it's that that addiction could be heroin,
methamphetamine,
cocaine,
it could be work,
sex,
video games,
whatever.
It's that same chemical pathway that's also associated with what chicks sent me
high called flow states.
It's that dopamine,
neurochemical pathways.
So when you channel focus that prime directive into a productive way that can
elucidate the flow state in that flow states essentially like your prime focus
on the current experience to the exclusion of everything else.
That's just like any kind of addiction that the mind can't rewrite,
it can't move away from.
So the definition of addiction is essentially like getting stuck in these
repetitive loops with something as the focus.
Even in the midst of detrimental experience,
you can't shift,
you can't break that cycle.
So it's doing something over and over and over,
even though you know that there's a bad consequence.
So his is an addiction
essentially.
Almost like a side effect of the process that's involved in us getting good at
something.
Because I've always found that in getting anything that I become obsessed with.
Anything that I really started wanting to get good at it,
it starts to permeate my life oftentimes in an uncomfortable way where it's
going on that like Eddie Bravo and I used to talk about this all the time with
Jujitsu that you would have like this underlying operating system that was
always doing Jujitsu that you,
you,
you would be,
if you were in a conversation with somebody and they wanted to talk to you
about,
well what the Democrats got to do is,
you know,
highlight the fact that we've created all these new jobs.
You just start thinking about choking people.
So I was just thinking like this is boring as fuck.
I'm going to concentrate on positions in my hand.
I'm going to nod my head.
But the,
the,
the Ma that what's going on behind the scenes,
the operating system,
what's,
what's always on his Jujitsu and almost everybody I know that is really good at
Jujitsu.
Thanks like that.
They all talk about how Jujitsu becomes almost like,
like a,
like a metronome in the background,
but it's like constantly going on.
And one of the benefits of that is that what you have this positive,
um,
really healthy,
uh,
rewarding experience that you're obsessed with.
So you're addicted,
but you're addicted to something that's super beneficial.
Hmm.
So that differential being that there's a positive outcome,
right?
Versus a negative outcome.
So you could describe that positive outcome experience,
even though it might be an addiction because the mind so focused on essentially
a flow state,
you just keep re accessing that flow state,
just reactivating something that for whatever reason,
the way it is engaging with your life and your mind is negative.
Like gambling addicts.
Yeah.
Like people were gambling addicts,
they just want that action all the time.
So,
and that's one of the,
that's one of the hardest addictions,
gambling,
because it's an intermittent reward.
You don't know what the outcome's going to be.
Oh.
So sometimes it's positive,
sometimes it's negative.
Look at it from the right perspective.
It's all negative because of the net loss.
And that's gamification to video games.
Same thing.
You don't yet know what the outcome's going to be.
So there's so much engagement,
heroin,
cocaine,
those kinds of substances,
you generally know what you're going to get.
So you can avoid those because you've experienced it,
you know what it is,
you know the negative repercussions of it.
You can step back.
Well,
it keeps,
it keeps people in [inaudible] right.
So the components of those addictions to,
right.
And that's why heroin so hard to kick and I began,
has like a 70% success rate and helping people kick heroin after one treatment.
That's pretty amazing.
That's pretty fucking amazing.
I know a good friend who has a with him was Oxycontin,
but essentially the same drug.
Right.
And uh,
he wanted to,
uh,
I went to Mexico,
took Ibogaine,
kicked it instantly,
and now he runs a treatment center down there for that very reason.
Yeah.
And,
and,
and the,
the long term predictor,
just to put that into context,
the longterm predictor is ongoing support.
So people have like recovery coaching.
Some people do 12 steps,
but the recovering coaching,
because I began itself as an addiction interrupter.
How does it,
what's the,
the actual physical mechanisms that are going on?
Well,
the psychedelic has wide variety,
but with Ibogaine particularly has an effect on the serotonin system,
the dopamine system,
and the opiate system or the opioid system.
It's one of the most complex interactions.
Most of the psychedelics operate on the serotonin system solely.
This ibogaine game acts on multiple systems across multiple fronts.
And so one of the reasons is particularly good for heroin is because it has that
unique profile of working on the opiate system.
What it seems to do as it goes in and it scrubs the opiate neurons completely
clean of the residue.
So when you look at the data,
people go through no or very little of the withdrawal symptoms.
Wow.
Right?
And that's the,
that's the biggest thing for people going through heroin on their own is to kick
it because they're just deathly afraid of the withdrawal that's going to come.
So they just keep getting stuck in the cycle.
So if you can offer them something held in the right set and setting,
that gives them the opportunity to rewrite it with very little discomfort.
Right.
Very little discomfort.
You're full of shit there.
Dot your fullest.
I just compressed,
they compress all of the horror of any kind of any kind of come down for that
few hours into your 40 hour,
two hours you guys need to come together and reach a consensus is few or is it
40 cause I you Bolga is
36 hours plus or minus.
For me it was 40 hours.
Both Times pretty intense.
I have a gain is the primary alkaloid.
There's 12 or so primary.
Eric lutes in Ebola,
which is the plant root itself.
I began as the extracted primary alkaloid that's used a safer therapeutic
window,
easier to dose,
easier to manage and it has a shorter half life.
So it's usually about 12 hours.
That's all just 12 hours where it feels like you're in a high voltage shed and
you're puking and you're spinning and there's a thousand pound pancake on you
and you're just being that this misery will end clean.
What do I have to do in my life that I never have to do a Bogo again?
But it's also you're examining like versus every aspect of,
so for,
for me,
going through your book,
I didn't have a,
I didn't have a drug addiction.
I was kicking,
I wanted to know the psycho spiritual implications.
And I also was trying it on because the clients that I kept,
um,
interfacing with,
I would do a lot of one on one work with clients and I knew the Boga or Ibogaine
was the right direction for them.
And they would ask me what's the experience like?
And as opposed to me saying,
well,
I've heard it's like x,
Y andZ ,
I need to actually go in the lab,
try it on for size so I can speak about it first person perspective.
So I did he boga twice.
And then when I came on board with crossroads,
um,
they work with Ibogaine and same kind of thing I needed to experience what it
was like for me actually I began,
was more intense than he bogan for most people.
It's the other way around.
Um,
but suffice it to say,
when you know that you're,
you're most people going through heroin or some kind of really bad addiction,
there are at a crossroads.
And so hence the name of the center.
They were at a crossroads where they have hit rock bottom and they know they're
at that level of desperation that if they don't make a significant shift than
some,
something really bad's going to happen.
Like they're going to die.
They're going to completely annihilate their entire family system,
whatever.
So they're coming with some motivation.
So when you,
when you let them know that,
yeah,
the experience can be potentially difficult.
And at crossroads it's the safest Ibogaine experience that you can have anywhere
because it's in a hospital clinical environments,
right?
Nick?
It's in Tijuana,
right next to Angeles hospital.
There's doctors on call right next door.
There's nurses on staff in the room.
You're wearing a holter monitor,
24 hour EKG monitor because people do die with Ebola and Ibogaine.
And usually it's because,
um,
they,
they weren't truthful and that they were using something long acting like
suboxone or methadone when they came in.
And you cannot be on a long acting opiate.
When you take your Boga bad news,
you can be on a short acting and then when that washes out,
you start the Ebola or Ibogaine.
And if everything's clean on board,
like they're not taking other drugs.
And I didn't only in their second month psychiatric medications,
the only other problem that people typically run into,
which isn't very common,
but it has happened,
maybe 1% of the time people will have an arrhythmia or a hot heart beat
irregularity because it drops your blood pressure and it drops your heart rate.
And if you're not wearing a monitor and you're not really paying attention,
what happens,
um,
then you can get in some trouble there.
So when,
if you have a crash cart on site,
it's fairly clinical setting,
then all those bases are covered.
So such in that set and setting,
it gets extraordinarily safe and you offer the people opportunity come through.
So when you're looking at it like from the uh,
Western addiction medicine perspective,
what are the numbers people go in?
What are the numbers of success rate?
People come in through an average,
um,
rehabilitation setting like up in Malibu.
Those numbers,
like maybe 15% plus or minus depending on the setting,
15% versus 60,
65 70% depending on the setting.
With the vulgar I began,
that's a 400 fold increase.
The difference being many factors,
the difference being that there's actually some physiological changes of this
drug is doing to your body.
And then also one inescapable fact of it is that the psychedelic experience is
pretty much all of them have that insane transcendent moment where you are
whatever the world that you were living in before you took that drug,
you were kind of basing your own experiences.
Like,
here's the range.
Here's the spectrum of experiences in life from my dog died too.
I got laid,
you know,
uh,
the birth of my child.
This is the,
this is the wonderful,
this is the awful.
And then you part the doors to the psychedelic experience and it's just like you
stepped outside like you thought the roof was the ceiling of the universe.
You stepped outside and realized,
Oh my God,
it's infinite.
You know?
It's like whoa.
So like the perspective change because they experienced is so intense and so
broad and so literally all encompassing.
So he got until two things going on.
You've got the,
the physiological change that something like I began can do and then you've got
the actual experience itself which is so transcendent and none of those things
are available in Malibu.
You go to,
I'm saying Malibu but you know any,
any of these I want to,
I was watching,
you know,
a periscope is this new thing that the kids or do wacky kids,
I was watching one yesterday,
I was just checking out different people's feeds and it was one from a rehabs
place like a house where these guys are all living together and rehabilitation
and I'm like this is like a weird social support system that they're trying to,
and they were talking about how great it is to not be drinking and you know,
I'm getting my life in order and I'm like this is like a very small shift that
they're doing.
They're trying to cling onto this small shift and hang on and
blow fire,
blow smoke on the blow air on the fire to try to get those embers to become a
flame or you jump into lava.
That's the other option.
Yeah,
right.
The thing about it Boga all these psychedelic experiences,
and I've done many of a variety of different durations from very short couple
minutes to very long like,
like a Boga and particularly with the plant medicines.
It's,
this seems to know how long it has.
Like
the half life for the medicine seems to be something that's already calculated
in your brain and so you get messages depending on how long you have,
you know,
a lot of times it's like a remarkable fact that I've noticed.
But with a Boga you have so much time that a boga just really takes its time and
relentlessly showing you all of the steps that you took to lead you to different
situations that you're not happy with.
I mean,
I remember when I did it the last time,
it took me,
like I spent about five hours showing me the hypothetical possible scenarios
that I could go with my life that wouldn't be beneficial,
that would be harmful to the world.
And it was like five hours of that.
Whereas like with Iowasca you'll get maybe,
you know,
half an hour that and then we'll be like,
okay,
but that's not reality.
This is it.
Like a Bogo has so much time that it just really beats these things to death.
So you won't even think about going down that road again.
Or if it's something and something that's in Congress,
in your life,
like a relationship,
you know,
you can wrestle with it.
I wrestled,
you know,
in another a Bogue experience.
I wrestled with a relationship I had for like eight hours.
And I'd say maybe this way it'd be like,
nope,
not this way because of this.
And it would show me the reasons why my logic was flawed and I ah,
and then I just come back again,
try another way.
And he's like,
nope,
not that way because of this.
You see you forgot 0.8 blah blah blah,
and it's just such a stern taskmaster when it comes to that and it has seemingly
infinite amount of time to just go through all of your rationalizations,
all your justifications.
You'd be like bullshit,
bullshit,
bullshit.
Showing it to you in a visual sense at vogue is a funny one because it's not as
visual as the other ones.
Like the DMT experiences particularly visual.
It Boga tends to be more thought based and when a vision needs to,
at least for me,
when a vision needed to have a visual explanation,
like it needed a visual cue,
it would come.
But a lot of times it's just directly thought based.
Almost like I was talking to a much smarter version of myself,
you know,
it was a really interesting way that interact because the visions were pretty
mild.
I would think the Boga in a sensory deprivation tank would be the ultimate,
well that might be,
that might be oh one to work up to.
And prior to that,
because like oftentimes if would ask me the question like,
okay,
I'm ready to have an experience,
where do I start?
So step number one is float and just float by yourself because a lot of people
haven't even floated yet and really looked at their stuff because interestingly
enough,
it starts to promote our own DMT like experience.
We see what's in the default mode network now comes online,
we're able to look at more introspective analysis and see what was just behind
the curtain that we didn't notice was there.
And now that comes onto the stage,
we can wrestle with that.
We can be with that and see what comes up,
make sure that we're okay with the unknown,
that kind of sense of dissolving back into the void.
And then you can start stacking therapies like doing something in the,
and so you're like,
you're more entry level.
Psychedelics would be like Mtma DMT or weed marijuana.
Um,
as as the next kind of entry point.
And then beyond that then you get into and silicide.
But I would put in that entry level point and then beyond that you get into the
second level and that's more like the pot what Chuma San Pedro Iowasca you boga.
And so it's,
it's nice to be able to know where people can start,
how to progress them through.
That's a lot of the psychedelic research is happening now is the,
is the correct screening to know who the experience is good for,
who it's not good for people with a history of psychosis and mania,
not good for people currently on psychiatric medications.
Not good for because most of the medicines in psychiatric medications don't work
well together and there was an energetic clash and you can have a real bad trip
where you could have physiologically dangerous things happen.
So when we know we know we've got this whole arsenal to work with and then it
becomes alchemy.
Knowing which medicine to use,
at which person,
at which time and in which sequence,
which order,
like what's your,
what are your targets,
symptoms.
If your targets symptoms are anxiety associated with um,
chronic pain,
well great.
Then it might be something like yoga is helpful because the book is really
helpful for pain because it's associated with that opiate um,
pathway.
And also let's prep with flotation and let's integrate with flotation because
flotation itself is also very good for pain.
Just flood,
just flotation by itself.
You start stacking therapies and I've seen clients and I've had clients that
have,
that have done a series of seven to 10 floats and all of a sudden now they're
off all their opiates before with with resolution of their underlying symptoms,
whether it's PTSD,
anxiety,
insomnia,
and then they do maintenance floats after that.
So two to three a week for like three or four weeks.
And then you do booster floats like one a month.
And some of the psychedelics are kind of similar.
When you go through a big experience,
you have a long period of integration and then maybe you do a booster shot.
Now the whole psychedelic experience here in the states is,
is under um,
uh,
renaissance.
There's a lot of energy moving.
There's a lot of,
um,
clinical trials coming up in really reputable centers like the Hopkins study
with Psilocybin,
massive that really puts silicide been back on the map,
um,
in the,
in the scientific community because of the study was so well designed and the
outcomes were so amazing that you couldn't refute it.
94% of people who were psychedelically naive had one of the top five spiritual
experience that I ever had and those,
and that experience lasted 14 months out with no side effects.
You're like,
holy cow,
that's pretty amazing.
MTMA assisted psychotherapy,
83% success rate for curing chronic severe PTSD after only two to three sessions
of MGMA supported psychotherapy.
So it's not just taking a drug and having your trip and all of a sudden now you
come out the other side resolved.
No,
it's like actually working with the trauma trained therapist and a really
supportive safe environment to work through that because Mgma is so good at the
d armoring that happens when people are traumatized and,
and the data is just so Ebola with addictions and um,
silicide been even with addictions.
There was,
there's just a recent pilot study that came out,
80% of people with chronic addiction to tobacco resolved after one time use of
psilocybin.
Right.
And so what's,
what's like the next second best thing that the allopathic medical community has
for that?
What's like Nicorette gum at like 80 at like 8% success rates.
You just went from 8% to 80% and oh by the way,
you just had a transformative mystical experience.
Yeah,
that was the side effects.
Talk to spirit guides.
It's awesome.
Awesome Shit.
You'll never forget that.
You'll tell people every time you see you talked to God CEO.
Exactly.
That's how I just don't understand how it's we,
we are here in this day and age with the thousands of years of people who've
been writing books and all that.
It's,
it's just amazing to me that they've been able to suppress some of the most
beautiful aspects of being a human being for so long.
And it seems like during our lifetime all this stuff is emerging.
Like some sort of a strange flower that refuse to be stuffed under the dirt.
It just,
the pop,
you know,
the,
the buds are just popping through the surface of the ground,
no matter how much pressure was put on it,
dropping,
you know,
rocks on it and stacking up shit and trying to hold it down with lies and
nonsense and pharmaceutical drugs and the lobbyists and all the pressure that
they put to keep this stuff down.
And then Johns Hopkins study comes out and it's like,
well you can't really refute.
I mean these are like some of the best minds in the world when it comes to these
subjects.
And then all the work that maps has done and that this has been amazing.
And the Internet itself,
the Internet itself,
I mean,
just the overwhelming amount of positive experiences,
anecdotal as they may be that people describe online,
it's,
it gives people this,
this community to draw from that doesn't exist in schools.
It doesn't exist in,
in most people's neighborhoods.
It doesn't exist where the,
where you would normally do find information.
You know,
look,
if you,
if you want to figure out how to fucking frame a house,
there's,
there's a hundred guys probably in your city that can show you how to do it.
And if you want to figure out how to contact a spirit guide and remove yourself
from an addiction that you have to pornography or to gambling,
or no,
good luck,
good luck.
You're just gonna,
you're gonna talk to some fucking guy who runs a church and maybe does good work
and he wants 10% of your money and wants you to sing and talk about Jesus and
it's not going to work.
Or you'll end up with the amethyst wand in your ass.
That could happen too.
Not knowing what's going on in the other way.
There's lots of people who will take advantage of that.
Of course.
And yeah,
this is,
uh,
certainly I think they've started something in motion that now can't be stopped.
What I think we're going to have to be careful of is,
you know,
with everything there's a certain point where medicine becomes poisoned and that
that happens with every single psychedelic,
you know,
where it crosses the threshold where it's no longer beneficial and it's
dangerous or the setting is wrong or the conflict is wrong and what's going to
happen and what we need to be careful of is that there,
there will be these bad incidents that come out just inevitably,
you know,
you hear about some of them from these,
pretty shady centers down in South America where people dive during Iowasca.
When that happens in,
you know,
on us soil,
which inevitably it will,
you know,
there's going to be this backlash and they're going to make one final push to
try and,
you know,
to try and stomp this out and we just have to,
really adhere to truth and,
and stay calm and try and put out as much good science as possible because
that's going to be the last card that they can play.
The numbers are just too high.
Yeah.
The problem with those,
those,
the numbers of negative,
the negative scenarios that they're depicting,
just the numbers of positive are so overwhelming.
There's no,
nothing is perfect.
Not,
not a single thing that you do.
You know,
there's people out there that they can't eat fish and you know,
they,
they try to have shell shellfish,
the,
their throat closes up.
It doesn't make sense,
but it just works that way.
It doesn't mean we should pull all the shrimp from all the markets.
Right.
It's just there's,
there's going to be negatives because we just have so much biodiversity.
There's so much difference.
If all the aspects that you were talking about that could be problematic.
People with psychosis,
history of mental health issues and drugs that they've been taking for these
mental health issues for long periods of times that have done all sorts of
really weird things.
Their brain chemistry,
that takes a long time to normalize from those numbers.
I mean,
as long as we're rational and honest about it,
the overwhelmingly positive aspects of these therapies are undeniable.
They're just too,
they're just too good.
Yeah.
Then the consumer driven movement has pushed it into the limelight and you've
had people that kept the torch like Rick Doblin with maps.
Yes.
And the next evolution of that now with a few really different key organizations
is to come up with a standard of a guideline for best practices.
And that's not to say that everybody has to adhere,
you know,
rock solid to these practices.
But generally what are the guidelines for practices?
You should be screening clients for these issues and if anybody has these
issues,
then they shouldn't into the experience.
This should be the general setting of the the right environment.
And this should be the ethical,
altruistic intention that people are coming to that experience in facilitation
that have,
that they're not doing it for profit and they're not doing it as some charlatan.
That they have a background,
they have a pedigree.
So,
you know,
it's like the [inaudible] check.
What's their energy?
What's their experience?
This is in the facilitation role.
What's their energy?
What's your experience?
And do they have the ability to work as a spiritual EMT?
Like if the shit goes down,
do they know how to pull the rip cord?
If somebody's going through the midst,
in the midst of some really bad experience,
do they know how to talk them down?
Bring the medicine down,
intervene in a way so that the experience doesn't itself become traumatizing.
What about food addictions?
You know,
it's interesting cause you were talking about the most difficult addiction to
quit being gambling.
Well that's as far as behavioral addiction,
but as far as
neurochemical addictions itself,
um,
sugar is up there with heroin.
And some studies show that sugar is even harder to kick than heroin.
And it's,
that's also a little challenging.
It's kind of like an addiction to technology.
Um,
food addictions are tricky because it's not like you're going to stop eating
right?
That's what I was going to bring up.
Right?
So there's a debate in,
in a variety of,
um,
addiction circles around moderation,
even with alcohol.
Um,
there's a movement in moderation where like,
you know,
the sponsor where the person helping coach of somebody going through sobriety,
we'll go to the bar and they'll have one drink and they'll talk about what it's
like to have one drink and then they'll leave together after only having like
one or two drinks without really reaching that point of significant detriment
and be able to process that whole experience so that you're not,
you're not trying to make this polarity statement like you went from this,
you know,
crazy addiction to now you can have anything.
And so if you're defining success as,
as being completely abstinent within,
maybe you're actually not appreciating the benefit of successive steps along the
way.
Like,
if somebody has a heroin addiction and they're not taking care of their family
and they can't hold a job and they go through some kind of recovery program,
or now they're using something else as maybe you had a transition addiction,
but they're holding a job now they're better with their family and wife and
kids.
There's very significant milestones and markers to where they have the,
they have improved their life.
In my experience,
that's,
that's success because you're moving towards ongoing improved benefit.
I had Dr. Andrew Hill on the podcast,
uh,
who,
has a,
a similar sort of a treatment approach.
And one of the things that he does is they'll,
they will go to a bar or the patient and have the patient have a drink and talk
them through it and make sure that they are only having one drink and that they
don't,
you know,
she's completely,
the goal should be
normalcy.
Not this like shaky damn.
Than if it leaks.
Right.
Thing floods,
you know,
one day at a time.
Yeah.
And everything just breaks,
you know,
you want to be,
you want to get to the point where you're so not addicted.
You're like everybody else.
If someone cracks a really nice bottle of wine at dinner,
you can say,
yeah,
sure,
you know,
if you want to not like,
ah Nah,
if I have that wine,
I'll be into the minibar and then it'll be like that fucking Denzel Washington
movie.
But isn't there a physical aspects to addiction that have to be addressed with
some people?
Totally.
Like some people really maybe should avoid alcohol almost entirely.
We will have a genetic predisposition towards hypersensitivity of the effects of
alcohol.
And you see that with Asian populations,
particularly Asian women.
You see that in the native American culture and population.
Um,
they have,
uh,
a weakness in a particular enzyme that breaks alcohol down alcohol dehydrogenase
and it actually turns alcohol into acid Aldehyde.
And it becomes this like really toxic substance.
And you,
you have long stream detriments and ramifications and neurochemical,
um,
complexity.
So you have a physiologic predisposition towards alcohol being really bad for
you.
And then you have the addiction.
Neurochemistry itself,
like we were talking about before.
And then you have everything underneath that which is the psychoemotional
psychospiritual implications.
Like what is empty from that person's life,
that that keeps them addicted to a substance that they're trying to fill a void
or numb a pain.
There's always these interplay of factors in it's important to look at all of
them.
And so whether it's alcohol or we were talking before about sugar,
sugar is one of the most addictive substances and it's,
it's really difficult to get completely away from,
you have to be really mindful about all the sugars that are added in fruit
juice.
Fruit juice seems healthy.
Yet when you look at the sugar load,
it's massive.
And my experience going with Ibogaine is that I didn't appreciate that I had
this long standing sugar addiction and in and looking back,
um,
I've had that for a long time.
And even looking back further,
I know now where it came from cause I,
I just kind of like did this retrospective analysis.
Um,
I was in and out of the hospital for the first two years cause I had recurrent
pneumonia.
I was six weeks early and in recurrent pneumonia they put you on a lot of
steroids in the,
put you on a lot of antibiotics in a completely script,
screws up your gut flora and it predisposes you to Candido long time down the
road and Candida feeds on sugar.
So after you know,
I was,
I was addicted to alcohol for a while and kick that and then I became addicted
to pot for a while and then I kicked that and then I became addicted to work and
kind of more monastic practices,
meditation,
those sorts of things.
And I lived in the jungle and he's kind of like extreme experiences,
but sugar was always in the background.
And then when I went through,
I began,
I came out and I have like zero on sugar now,
zero because you recognize what it really is because it shifted the
neurochemistry.
So without even knowing going in that there was this addiction there,
because I would just wasn't registering it consciously.
Did sugar addiction for somebody with,
with a week metabolic load or maybe they're susceptible,
they have adrenal fatigue or they're susceptible to hold on to weight.
Maybe a sugar addiction is a really bad thing because now you can see that
they've got this metabolic syndrome and they're moving into type two diabetes or
whatever it might be.
Um,
for me it was always kind of in the background,
but it was always there.
Like,
I have a sweet tooth that's insatiable.
If I kick it off,
I go rampant.
Right?
And so on the other side of Ibogaine,
there's no charge on sugar now.
And I didn't even know that was going to come out the other side.
I just ended up,
um,
everybody was feasting on sugar at this party.
I was at like a few days later and,
and I had this kind of like,
um,
I was just,
I just kind of looked at it and glanced away and I thought,
well that's different.
I remember that there would be this charge before and,
and now there's nothing.
And so there isn't there.
There's a whole thing that happens with addictive neurochemistry that might not
necessarily be,
and that's all physiologic,
right?
I mean,
ultimately at the,
at the end of the day,
we're all energy.
We're like 99.997% energy.
This is just space.
So we're like,
you should have like these energetic beings and these all these implications
around that depending on your spiritual and philosophical beliefs about what
causes that to be the case.
We're also in this three d reality.
We have these monkey suits that were wearing and sometimes a cigar is just a
cigar.
So if you have a candy to overgrowth,
it feeds on sugar.
It's good to get rid of that in order to release the sugar.
And you have to do that mindfully too,
because candy to buffers heavy metals,
we were talking about heavy metals before,
so when people go on these crash,
no sugar diets,
oftentimes the candy to die off and it releases this massive toxic load on the
system and that's why people feel shitty.
It's not necessarily because of Candide is going away.
It's because of all the things that the candy to released.
So you have to be mindful about how do you,
how you detox and stop waste fashions.
And it can get a little bit complicated,
but we can do it well.
So that's just a long way to say for me personally,
and I've seen this with other clients to say that same thing,
but until I had the experience myself,
I really wasn't putting it in first person perspective and really appreciated
the fact that just by itself,
you can see this too with people coming off of the streets on heroin just by
itself.
There's a neurochemical,
addictive rewrite,
a reboot in that system that helps people.
That's why it's an addiction interrupter.
There's a really good documentary called,
um,
I begin rites of passage,
I think it was been maybe eight years ago or so,
and it's really well done.
Kind of like neurons to Nirvana,
which was more recent.
Also,
another really good one,
um,
that talks about that addictive neurochemical rewrite.
Flotation does that too.
It's just not as big and you have to do a lot of floats.
So when that neurochemical rewrite is,
is happening and that interruption occurs,
then you do the ongoing supportive work.
And so like addiction recovery coaching,
like,
okay,
what was underneath that?
And through the experience,
through this mystical experience,
now you're reframing so much of the childhood trauma,
the trauma and addiction are extraordinarily interwoven trauma,
Adhd and addiction are extraordinarily interwoven.
So when we understand the,
the neurological implications,
the trauma implications,
the transgenerational implications,
right?
So if people have problems with their genetics,
there's a whole now burgeoning field called nutrogenomix or detoxing genomics
where you do these genetic profiles and it shows you what you were ability to
detox certain things.
Ours,
and when we were talking about heavy metals,
like we're too heavy metals come from,
well,
it's like kind of like when people are exposed to the flu.
The flu is everywhere.
But some people express it because some people's immune system is weakened or
they have a predisposition.
So heavy metals are everywhere and environmental toxicities everywhere.
When you look at the fetal cord blood baby just born,
the average number of toxins in that fetal cord blood 220 average toxins right
out the gate.
60 of those are known carcinogens right out the gate.
You're already like born and we're born into this toxic soup.
So if we know what our genetics are,
and Rhonda was talking about this in regards to Doctor Rhonda Patrick the cause
that was a great podcast you did with Tbi and she was talking about the
predisposition towards Alzheimer's.
You have these eight po e type for genetics.
Well,
if you put that genetic profile on top of a traumatic brain injury,
now you just have an increase in your Alzheimer's risk tenfold.
Do you think that people are hesitant to,
um,
to,
to look at sugar the same way you're describing it because it doesn't have the,
like when you say that sugar is more addictive in some studies than heroin,
people will go off.
That's fucking horse shit.
But it's because they effect of sugar.
It doesn't have the profound effect on the body that heroin does the actual
effect.
But I think people might confuse that with the addictive properties of it.
Cause I know a lot of fucking people that are addicted to sugar and they don't
want to admit it and they die.
They want to pretend that it's just,
it's normal if they didn't take a day off of sugar and they feel like they did a
great thing a day,
you know,
I mean I don't know if heroin junkies needed every day,
if they could take a couple of days off.
But I've,
I've seen friends that he eat candy or drink soda and those motherfuckers,
they,
it calls them,
it calls them after
every meal,
after every meal.
They have to finish it with something sweet.
You have to have a dessert.
And I've,
I've con I've felt myself go in and out of these modes where it's like I want a
piece of chocolate or something after almost every meal.
No.
And then I'll be off to be like,
Whoa,
whoa.
What is that?
Yeah.
Like why,
why am I so compelled to do that?
And the more stressed I am and the more I am doing things,
just kind of an autopilot,
the more I just do that without even thinking like the more if I've been in a
recent medicine journey or if I've gone floating or if I've kept up with my
meditation practice,
well then I can like stop and reflect and be like,
okay,
here's this urge welling up inside me.
Do I want to say she ate it or do I want to,
you know,
deny it and you have more conscious control of it.
And then at that point you can really make a decision.
But when you're just caught up in momentum,
you know,
we're such creatures of momentum that that's,
you have to halt the momentum with what the native Americans would call the
sacred silence,
which is anything that brings you to a point of presence where you can really
access free will and just kind of stop all this momentum that's going is why the
tank is so great.
Ultimate nature meditation.
I mean all of these things,
you know I was,
I'm reading this book right now,
but by Tom Brown called awakening spirits and he gives this really cool little
fable that explains it.
So they'll tell the fable here.
So there's this guy who lives in the woods with a wizard and this wizard has a
demon that can accomplish any task.
So the guy wants to capture this wizard and get the demon cause he wants to
accomplish any task.
So he finds the wizard and meditation down by the Stream,
throws a rope around him,
cinches it tight and the wizard looks at him and says,
you've come from my demon,
haven't you?
Says yes,
I've come to the game and give it to me or I won't let you go.
It says,
that's fine,
I'll give you the demon.
But I have to tell you,
the demon will do anything you want,
but you have to keep it busy.
If you don't keep it busy,
it will go angry.
It'll grow hostile,
it will seek to destroy you.
He says,
fine,
no matter what,
whatever.
I'll keep it busy.
There's plenty of stuff to do was it says,
sure,
the demon will be waiting for you back to your house.
So it goes back to his house and there's the demon.
It's a nice,
humble servant,
says,
what can I do for you master?
He says,
I'll go fetch me a cup of water,
and the demon goes out and comes right back with a cup of water.
It says,
it has done drinks the water.
He says,
what else would you have me do?
ah,
go make me a feast.
Go Hunt some game and make me a feast.
So demon goes out and makes them a feast,
comes back,
it has done,
and B,
even before he could finish eating it,
the demon starts growing more angry and bigger and says,
what will you have me do?
What will you have me do?
It says,
ah,
built me a new house.
Okay,
so the demon goes off and gets a moment of rest.
The demon comes back,
says it has done.
The man looks up.
Sure enough,
there's the house built and he runs out of things.
He starts to panic.
He runs out of things to do.
So he's freaking out.
He runs back to where the wizard was.
It said,
wizard,
I can't,
I can't stop
it.
The,
I can't give the demon enough things to do.
And the wizard says,
you know,
with compassion says pull a hair from your head and tell the demon to straighten
the hair.
And he says,
okay,
I guess I'll try that.
So he runs back and at this point that the demon is fully out of control.
It's destroying his house.
It's destroying all the things that he loves about his house.
So he pulls the hair from his head and he says,
straighten this hair.
And so the demon gets the hair it sa tries to straighten it and the hair goes
back to curly,
tries to straighten the hair,
goes back to curly,
strives to straighten it hair.
It goes back to curly and all of a sudden the demon shrinks in size.
And so in this fable,
the demon is our minds and our minds are constantly requiring,
you know,
what will you have me do?
What will you have me do?
And many of these techniques that we use,
they like into the hair.
It's something that allows the mind,
gives it a moment of distraction,
gives it something to occupy.
It,
puts it to sleep so that we can use the mind is a servant instead of our master.
And so all of these things from meditation to floating to Psychedelics,
you know,
their hairs,
even nature itself is in its way a hair.
Because if you need nature to find that calm,
that's,
you know,
that's the hair you need that walk in the mountains and some hairs are better
than others,
obviously.
I love the story up to the hair part.
I think whoever wrote that store,
it needed to go back for a second draft.
I like what they're saying,
I,
I catch it,
but straighten the hair out.
This fucking thing can build houses.
It can't straighten the hair out to goddamn demon.
It has powers.
Right.
Feel like it should of told it.
Uh,
what I would like you to do is shut the fuck up.
How about concentrating on shutting the fuck up and doing nothing?
That's what I'd like you to do.
That's your task.
Your task is to do nothing.
Well,
if Tom Brown,
if you're listening,
you need to rewrite your story touches on it.
That's what old shit that was written a long time.
But people had a lot of curly hair will be real dumb shit.
They wrote no on the Ark.
You know,
two of each animal.
The Fuck Outta here.
The animals eat animals.
What are they doing on that boat?
What do they do when they get off the boat?
You fucked up.
The guy's made bad stories.
I liked that.
The idea though,
but it,
cause it is kind of true that like,
especially ambition,
you know,
ambition can get out of control.
It's like we were what we were discussing earlier today about rich people,
that there's a certain amount of rich people that never feel like,
you know,
one,
I've made plenty of money.
I don't have to gouge and,
and fuck over all the people that I do business with and try to rip off everyone
who is,
uh,
you know,
who's working with me.
You know,
you could,
you could have some sort of a,
a more more peaceful relationship with them if you're less concerned about the
money.
And you brought up a really interesting point is that's the only thing they're
keeping score in.
The only thing where they have like a number system or a a like you could look
up on the board like look,
we're making progress.
Look at,
we have a quantifiable progress report right up on the board.
And those things become,
it becomes a part of who you are as a human being,
how you interface with this reality and your self worth and your,
how you,
uh,
w the way you appreciate yourself and the way you feel about yourself.
Your confidence is oftentimes based entirely on how those numbers are moving and
when those,
when it's all just about business,
you know,
it's about selling computers or whatever the fuck you're doing.
Like,
you know,
like Steve Jobs I think completely lost the script when you're talking about a
guy who got into this idea of creating computers and,
and,
and figuring out something that the fix the world through psychedelics.
He got into it through LSD and these LSD experiences that he had.
He said,
where were some of the most powerful experiences of his life?
Well,
what did it lead to lead to a guy who was fucking not,
it was working 20 hours a day,
just making computers all the time and trying to stop the competition and shut
down anyone that would oppose him and yelling at his employees,
screaming at them,
even for not working as hard as he worked,
like not recognizing that they're just individuals that are working for him.
They're not going to share that same sort of psychotic passion.
Yeah,
I mean I think we're all,
we're all hungry for more.
We're insatiable creatures.
We ought,
we require more air,
we require more food.
We require more water where generally insatiable beings and we require progress.
You know,
that's one of the things we require puzzles.
And the problem is,
is that there's a hunger inside ourselves that oftentimes we don't know where
the,
where the mouth is defeat it.
And that's this,
you know,
this true peace,
this,
this alignment and reconciliation with our consciousness that whatever higher
self that is,
call it spirit,
call it whatever you want.
I prefer to call it your consciousness.
And the problem is,
is that it's really close to the other stomachs,
but it's not it.
So people try to feed it with accomplishments,
with money,
and they feed it with relationships and status and all of these other things,
but they're not actually nourishing what that real hunger is.
And that's the hunger to be what we're capable of.
Being on a true consciousness level and a being that can help make the lives of
everyone else around us better improve the quality of life for the earth and
everybody around.
Yeah.
That's,
uh,
it's so hard to grasp if you're not in that mindset.
It's so hard to,
to leave the momentum of your current mindset,
whether it's a current mindset that loves to gamble or the current mindset loves
to stuff your fat face with cake,
whatever it is.
Those mindsets that those patterns of behavior are incredibly difficult to
escape from.
And it's one of the reasons why I wanted to ask you about food addictions cause
it seems to me that it's got,
I don't,
I don't really have a food addiction,
but would imagine that
they're probably one of the hardest to kick because everybody has to eat
totally.
You have to eat.
Yeah.
So while you're eating and you're like,
yeah,
the salary is good,
but fuck,
it would be awesome if I had some chocolate ice cream right now.
What some whipped cream and chocolate fudge,
you know,
those,
uh,
those whole filling,
longing,
lust,
full sort of intense cravings that some people have towards food.
I've seen friends that have food addictions that are,
that when they do get that food,
like,
you know,
we're maybe driving somewhere,
maybe we're hungry.
Me,
we just landed and we're on our way from the airport to get food.
When they get finally get that food,
it's like a fucking guy.
He's been holding his breath at the bottom of the ocean.
They can't.
This is all ah,
ah,
ah.
It's like,
like you just,
you just did something like you,
you kept yourself from my precious for so long.
Then when you finally in the,
in the presence of it,
you just gorging it.
We fucking forget to breathe.
You're not breathing.
I've seen guys eat or they're not breathing.
You're not like taking a buy.
You are fine.
Five minutes ago you were beating,
your heart was beating,
you were breathing,
you are walking your feet,
but then all of a sudden that chicken parm sub comes your way and you're just
stuffing into your fucking mall.
That's a weird addiction,
man.
It's a weird addiction and that imbalance of massive necessity,
you know,
it's necessary to get it in me right now even though it's not really.
Yeah.
Food addiction is,
is one of the trickier ones,
and not everybody's going to do a psychedelic,
right.
So for the vast majority,
like not everybody's going to climb Everest and when you climb Everest,
it's going to have a map and a team and the guide and all that stuff.
Don't sit there when there's an earthquake.
Right?
Right.
Yeah.
You want them to set and setting,
right.
Same thing.
So what are,
what is most people are going to do?
Well when you,
when you transition off of something that's so ubiquitous,
it's super helpful to have motivation because it's not going to be an easy
journey.
It's super helpful to have a guide and a plan and it's super helpful to
integrate that plan and stay,
you know,
stick to it.
So sugar,
um,
there's a,
Jj virgin is a really well known author in the whole addiction realm,
particularly in regards to sugar.
She's got a pretty successful plan.
Basically it entails,
I'm stepping down and then transitioning from sugars that are really crappy to
sugars that are better and then less of those sugars that are better to
eventually on extraordinarily or no sugar diet.
So you gradually step that down and outside of having a really good motivation,
sometimes people won't stay stay with it like,
oh this is just too hard.
But if your motivation is like,
wow,
I just went to the doctor and I've got like,
you know,
90% stenosis on one of my,
um,
heart arteries and I'm really close to having an another heart attack,
or I'm morbidly obese and some,
and I just got that major self reflection about how my life's just horrible
right now.
Or I'm in this,
you know,
suicidal depression and whatever,
whatever people's motivation is,
that crisis point can actually help people motivate them to a new trajectory.
So that's why often have you here with,
with anybody going through an addiction,
particularly with alcoholics and they haven't hit rock bottom.
And once you've motivated and you've,
you've come up with a plan,
whatever that plan is to be able to stick to it is also important than to have
ongoing support,
especially if these are dangerous addictions.
Like my sister committed suicide a year and a half ago after she relapsed on
alcohol and no one saw it coming.
And she shot and killed herself.
And it was a really big shock and it,
it really helped,
um,
remind me of the importance of ongoing support and being consistently,
interfacing with conscious people in our family and supportive tribe and our
brothers and sisters,
like really watching out for each other,
really checking in,
making sure there's not anything going on in deeper level,
having that honest inventory versus just playing on the surface and ignoring
everything that's in the background.
And,
and this life is precious,
right?
So when we engage it in a good way and we're becoming our best self,
then we have the opportunity to really create massive beneficial change in the
world.
And many people are,
are playing on the surface and we don't exactly even know how to get in touch
with ourselves or what we want to do or what our mission is here in life.
And so coming back to that whole addiction rewrite,
there's steps,
there's a very clear steps along the path and sugar's one of those that is
because it's so ubiquitous or like technology.
Um,
I used to help run a clinic called alternative to meds in Sedona and another
place called the sanctuary in Sedona to different centers.
But oftentimes people will come for addiction recovery.
And one of the trickiest ones that we ever saw was this addiction to technology,
whether it was pornography or just being on the Internet for so long,
um,
or whatever kind of addiction profile in the technology arena.
Because it's like sugar,
it's so ubiquitous.
It's not like you're going to just say no and I'm never going to do that again.
It's like,
so at that point it's,
it's even coming back to that moderation planets even more helpful to have an
ongoing support system and person in place and recovery coach move you through
that process.
So sugar is one of those that,
because it's a physiologic addiction,
the body does get used to it or caffeine.
It does get used to it.
So if people are jacked up on coffee,
you transitioned a black tea,
then you transition to green tea and then you transitioned to no caffeine,
really set somebody up for success versus saying,
Oh,
you're on coffee,
then stop it cold Turkey and suffer for you know,
a to 10 days.
Most people are going to want to do it that way and it doesn't actually have to
go that way.
You can actually come up with a pretty successful plan.
You just have to be rock solid and committed to it.
When you're talking about Ken Dda and gut bacteria,
how much of a,
when when you try to help someone get off that,
how much emphasis do you put on probiotics?
Massive.
Because there's going to be a die off and that that die off and that toxicity
that the candied is going to release or Paris in like if you're clearing
parasites,
same thing.
So parasites are another buffer.
And we,
we have grown and we were talking about this before,
we've,
we've grown over generations in traditional cultures to be symbiotic with,
with uh,
parasites in our environment.
Like we live together.
And you see these traditional cultures like that are very untouched by western
food and by Western marketing,
when by Western influence and when you look at their microbiome or you look at
their gut flora,
they have the most rich and diverse gut flora and the ones that we usually have
in like probiotic strains are just a fraction of everybody who's playing.
And so you've got these massively complex and extraordinarily sophisticated gut
probiotic populations that help us metabolize and even produce a lot of them
micronutrients that we need for our most vital living.
And when you look at the longterm ramifications of being able to reinfeldt
trait,
and so there's this whole movement now around fecal transplants and being able
to identify somebody who's got a really healthy microbiome or healthy gut flora,
they have a healthy neurological system.
They're just generally vital as a source for a potential gut fecal transplant.
And when you look at people who are kind of the opposite of that,
they have long standing,
irritable bowel syndrome or Crohn's disease or some kind of autoimmune
infection.
There's a,
there's a,
there's a whole science around using parasites is actually a beneficial step.
It's called helminthic therapy.
We actually receive hookworms into the system and the hookworms kind of move
everything else out and lower the inflammatory load and help to rewrite some of
that autoimmune cascade.
So then once that autoimmune cascade has rewritten,
then you bring in the healthy probiotics.
So there's,
there's a whole science to the gut,
body and mind interface.
It's where there's a really good book,
I think,
by getting Gerson called the second brain.
And it's this whole deep scientific look at the gut brain connection and how
many of the neurotransmitters and what build the neuro transmitters that
actually starts in the gut.
Like most of the serotonin system comes from the gut.
It doesn't come from the brain,
it's produced in the gut and it's transported to the brain for activity.
So people that talk about feeling like shit,
it's because they're,
they're,
they're full of Shit,
right?
So we need to actually start with the gut.
Isn't it
amazing how much diet and what you take into your body has an effect on your
mind itself?
I mean,
it really,
really,
truly is amazing how much what you put into your body has an impact on how your
brain functions and the fact that we never get taught that our bodies are
essentially a biological ecosphere.
I mean,
your,
your bodies are essentially not one thing.
You're,
but your bodies are like a host of untold billions of little tiny microscopic
life forms that exist.
And if they're in an unhealthy state,
you'll be in an unhealthy state.
But if they're in a healthy state,
you'll feel better.
The,
the,
the studies that they've done on probiotic gut content and the effect that it
has on depression.
Massive.
It's insane.
Massive anxiety to anxiety,
right?
You,
you,
you have like a healthy rat population and ancient,
uh,
anxious rat population.
You take out their poop and you transplant it.
You just turn the healthy rats into anxious rats in the anxious rats,
in a healthy rats.
In all fairness,
you're fucking with her butt and sticking improvement.
External factors
like I was fine.
They started metal rod up.
My ass man has nothing to do with the pope.
You put in there.
Like,
I'm wondering when the next fucking shoe's going to drop.
We haven't gotten sophisticated yet and being able to like measure like how rats
feel cool we have about that.
Be Able to press a button and freeze them in time so they don't know what we're
doing to them.
Right.
You know,
it's an interesting thing because there was a study that was done on rats with
Coke Keynes,
a very famous study,
the difference between cocaine and heroin and rats and that if you give these
rats cocaine,
they'll do cocaine until they die.
The problem with that study,
it's been brought up,
uh,
I forget who,
who was on the podcast,
it brought it up was that you're talking about rats in a fucking cage.
Yeah.
What else can take do?
The cage itself is a part of the study and the followup study to that showed
that when they're put in a rat park and they're still given unlimited supply of
cocaine.
So in in isolation,
rats with unlimited supply of cocaine,
more than 75% will be heavy users.
And a lot of lethality when that same unlimited supply of cocaine is put in the
setting of what's called the rat park,
where you're now you're like hanging out with a rat rat,
hookers,
you got back the rat rat softball game going on all of your options,
joggers got mouse racing,
you've got all kinds of shit.
And when you've got all this great stuff and stimulation around you,
you've just went from over 75 heavy users to less than 25% heavy users and know
lethality,
right?
So you,
you,
because of the social stimulation.
So addiction is about connecting,
life is about connection,
right?
So that address,
that ability to connect to like a stimulating environment,
the social mill,
you significantly drops the,
the drug use,
even if you have the same amount.
And same thing with Portugal when they legalized all drugs.
Uh,
and that would be decriminalized.
I was that correct?
Yeah.
Decriminalized and sell them.
But yeah,
yeah.
Sorry.
Good.
Yeah.
Right.
So when decriminalization happened and then they shifted all their money from
the war on drugs into social infrastructure and started to boost up the social
mill you and started to de stigmatize the addiction nomenclature and that label
like something's wrong with you.
Like actually let's talk about what's going on in your social arena and how we
can help that.
It was a complete rewrite and drug use went down,
lethality went down.
So we're recognizing just more and more and these like we as these like,
you know,
monkeys walking around in these suits,
we are built for a connection and win.
That's why,
you know,
are our,
the first part of our whole discussion today around people doing,
you know,
thumb desk jockey and getting really absorbed into that whole gamification arena
and the whole video gaming industry.
I get concerned about the social developmental ramifications.
Like what,
what's the potential end result and does the,
is is that beneficial for,
you know,
for the evolution of our species,
so so to speak or is it going to end up being like idiocracy where generations
down the load
down the road we just get dumber and dumber and then you know,
the president is a,
I think it really just needs to be,
it depends on title holder.
It depends on just how much addiction you have to,
whether it crosses that threshold.
Because I played a lot of video games,
they kind of sucked back when I was a kid.
But you know,
it was always the balance was I play some video games and then run around
outside play basketball or kick a ball around or do whatever.
And,
but I played it.
I mean I played a good amount.
There was days I would play six,
eight hours a dragon warrior or final fantasy or whether he's in the game grand
scheme of things.
You were probably doing much more athletics,
social,
but still it was just about,
you know,
about balance.
And I think again,
that same message,
if we demonize video games,
the kids are going to be like,
fuck you.
Because they know that that's inherently not the problem.
The problem is,
is identifying when something good like sex becomes something not good like
addiction to sex.
If that thing is even real.
I mean I imagine it is.
Totally.
Yeah.
Okay.
Sex Addiction is extraordinarily addiction to washing your hands.
Yeah.
People have addictions to everything.
I mean there's people that have addictions to they,
they really get physically upset if they step on cracks in the sidewalk.
Right.
This is more like an obsessive
compulsive disorder kind of complex,
but don't you think that there's some sort of an addiction property to that?
Like you're at OCP is another floor.
Oh,
cds.
Another really difficult one to to rewrite and interestingly enough,
when you look at the studies,
the angiogenes and the psychedelics,
they come in again to help rewrite the neurochemistry that's a bit more
serotonin and driven and nuts.
So much dopamine driven.
There's some crossover lap,
but that's more of an anxiety spectrum disorder versus primary addiction
disorder because those ritualized behaviors have to be done in order to arrest
some underlying compulsion and um,
and,
and need for perfection and need to have a corrective experience,
some kind of underlying need.
And so there's the energy around,
it's a little bit different,
but at the same time the intervention for success and recovery from that might
be pretty similar because everybody's a little bit different when you look at
the data.
People that have significant anxiety,
and this actually came up with floating too two years ago,
Justin Feinstein talked about flow to at the float conference.
He was talking about the benefits of flotation for anxiety and people with
generalized anxiety disorder after 10 floats had significant reduction in their
symptoms,
like by the order of like 30%.
And people with,
um,
uh,
obsessive compulsive disorder,
significant improvement in symptoms when going through a psychedelic experience
like Iowaska.
So you've got these,
again,
the really novel treatments and Therapeutics and more honestly,
more people are going to float,
then more people are going to do psychedelics.
But again,
it just becomes a really wide array of our,
of our tool belt and knowing how to meet people where they're at,
recommend the rights,
the right approach for them at that time.
Oftentimes floating is a gateway to do other things like clean up the Diet,
clean up your social environment and get more on track with your purpose and
your passion.
Cause like when you're driving your purpose and your passion,
all of a sudden there's less bandwidth that even has room to play with other
behaviors and other addictions that might not be getting you to that point.
Yeah.
I,
I've got to think that momentum plays a huge factor in a lot of people's lives
and their decisions both good and bad.
When people are on the,
the bender momentum,
they're getting drunk every night and they're fucking up every night.
It becomes their life.
Whereas the momentum of positivity that becomes their life.
When you start talking about expressions and sayings like one day at a time.
The,
the issues that I have with that,
uh,
I'm talking completely out of ignorance because I'm not an alcoholic and I never
have been.
But if I was,
I would like to think that I could just get rid of it.
It doesn't have to be one day at a time.
Like why,
why is it one day at a time?
Well,
I wake up tomorrow,
am I going to be,
am I going to fuck up?
Like am I putting
that out there?
That one day at a time means let's just take this one day at a time.
I'm sober one day at a time.
How want I'm fucking sober.
How about this is me,
I learned from the past and I'm sober now,
but the people that are into that 12 step shit,
the,
my only concern is they talk a lot like crossfitters.
They talk like vegans and crossfitters and people that are like really into
being addicted to what they're into.
They're addicted to sobriety.
Like they start talking about it all the time.
They start like trying to encourage other people.
Even people that don't have a problem with alcohol,
like I've had friends that got clean and then they see you have a drink and
they're like,
listen bitch,
see this.
This is a beer.
I like beer.
I'm going to have appear and then I'm done.
Is that okay?
By the way,
I'm going to get up in the morning,
I'm going to run.
You want to run with me pussy.
He just going to sit in bed and,
and it'd say wondered torm I'm going to go have my coffee and my cigarettes
cause I'm super healthy.
That's the other thing they do.
They get addicted to something else.
It becomes an addiction to a new thing.
Coffee and cigarettes is a big one with alcoholics.
I mean I know so many fucking alcoholics said,
you see them every day.
They have a Goddamn Venti Starbucks in their hand.
They can't get off that tit and it's just,
they've just substitute it.
Whatever it is that they were trying to fill with the booze,
they've substituted it now with caffeine or with nicotine or with whatever air
becomes like an identifying part of their story.
That's part of their identity.
And I think one of the Lewer,
one of the lures and the problems with this is when you have this kind of
ascetic principle that's part of your identity,
you think you're doing great things,
but you're really just focused entirely on yourself.
It's like,
I'm doing something great,
I'm eating Vegan.
Well what is that doing for the world?
That's just something you're doing for yourself.
Fine,
good.
But they act like it's this great burden that they've bore for the rest of
humanity will do it.
There's kind of an argument for that because the less carbon footprint,
less of an impact on the environment with no factory farming or no vested
interest in that.
So there's a modicum of,
there's a modicum of actual benefit,
but in any kind of aesthetic practice,
whether it's not drinking or whether it's not eating meat or whether it's not,
not doing something not,
not engaging in sex,
you know,
you can talk to somebody who's celibate and you find these in some yoga
community.
He's like,
yes,
you know,
I've,
I've not engaged in sex and in a month,
and they act like they're doing some great service for humanity when really it's
a selfish thing that they're doing fine if you want to do that.
Any of these things are good.
I'm not saying don't do them,
but the lure is that because it's a struggle.
You feel like you're doing something great when really you're just focused
entirely on yourself.
Well,
there's also a competition going on and there's comparing yourself to others,
which is,
it's a natural human instinct.
It's a natural human instinct to gauge your progress based on you,
how
you,
how you stack up with the people that you surround yourself with.
And very,
very few people like to do that in the negative sense.
Like you don't like to look at that in a negative sense.
You know,
you like to look at it in a positive sense.
Like if you're,
you've,
you've turned Vegan,
one of the things that people like to do is say they get really shitty,
especially online like online,
like the ability to communicate with people with no social repercussions,
no queues,
no interaction,
no look at each other eye to eye this,
this shitty,
nasty things that people say to each other through that and that this,
this Vegan thing that so many people love to do where they are really fucking
angry and nasty and aggressive towards people who aren't Vegan and towards
people who enjoy meat or towards people who hunt and they somehow or another
feel like they're justified in releasing his anger on you and because you're
cruel to animals.
Like I saw something today or someone was talking about there's bears in
Yellowstone park that we're chasing tourist.
Did you see that video?
It was pretty crazy video.
These people were all on this,
uh,
this,
bridge and these black bears start chasing these people.
It's really kind of fucked because there's quite a few people on this bridge and
they got on a bridge that unfortunately a mother and her cubs got on and the
mother's kind of freaking out and she's chasing people off.
And so someone,
you know,
someone was like,
man,
fuck those bears.
Like somebody wrote that on Twitter.
And then some other guy was like,
no fuck people.
You know what people do to this world.
If you compare what bears do this world and go la,
la,
la La.
And it was like this angry scribe about veganism.
And I'm like,
went from bears being around people too.
I'm better than you because I'm a Vegan and people suck.
But bears are awesome.
That bear will eat your dick off and not give a shit.
You can be screaming.
It's living in nature and is trying to keep its babies alive.
Which by the way,
if it runs into a male bear,
the male bears going to eat the babies.
So please shut the fuck up with people are worse than bears cause it's
ridiculous.
If bears had cars,
they would never get their oil changed.
They would fucking g drive right over babies.
They wouldn't give a fuck.
I'm going to get to the idea,
the idea that somehow or another,
you know,
you,
you have transcended,
you know,
your,
your need to consume animal protein.
And so this has transformed,
transferred in,
in your being somehow to this anger towards people that do consume animal
protein.
It's really short sided and it does more harm than it does good because there's
some really good ideas that are attached to living a vegetarian life.
Really good ideas.
And what,
what you're just talking about in regards to both of those groups.
Like you had the guy who was recovering from alcohol,
now he was judging you for drinking a beer and you've got vegans who
are judging you for eating meat.
It's the same under,
under both of those is that same projected um,
bias.
It's that same judgment that what I'm doing is right and what you're doing is
wrong.
And when we do that,
we polarize the discussion and to meet some people good.
And some people bad as opposed to in western medicine has done that to
chiropractic medicine or naturopathic medicine.
I mean,
or the Palestinians have done that to the Israelis are,
I mean the,
the inherent conflicts that are downstream that caused all the major discourse
in the world is all about people judging one another and the,
and believing in their bones that their position is right versus coming to the
table and saying,
let's connect.
Let's have a clear conversation.
Let me own what is mine.
So if I'm a recovering alcohol and I'm judging you for your alcohol and maybe
let me own the fact that I'm actually envious of you because I'd really love to
have a beer,
but for me,
because of my chemistry or my background or whatever because of who I am and
what I'm going through right now,
I me having a beer is a bad thing.
Yeah.
It would lead to a bad outcome.
So I'm going to judge you for yours.
It doesn't really matter.
You can put the mask on any way you want,
but underlying that it's people's own inherent ability to be real and okay with
themselves and judging each other as being bad or wrong.
That's the,
that's the polarizing conflict.
Yeah,
that's a very good point.
It's a very good point.
And I think it speaks to what we were talking about earlier about competition
and that this is the only arena where they're keeping score and that some
people,
they're keeping score with their moral there.
The,
the,
the like the moral score.
Like I am a more moral and more ethical person of you because I choose to live
my life in this way even though I do all sorts of damage to people's psyche by
being shitty to them.
Because,
you know,
because of the fact that they're not living the same moral life than I do.
This is the issue that I've had with,
you know,
the quote unquote social justice warriors of the world,
the people that shame and attack people for having what they believe to be
disparaging belief systems or,
or uh,
people that may be sexist or homophobic or what have you,
instead of,
instead of treating these ideas with a rational discourse and love,
they,
they're aggressive and angry and they tried to get people fired and they tried
to shame people for their ideas.
That doesn't work.
You can't,
the human beings don't work like that and you can't communicate like that.
And what you're doing is essentially the same thing that we're talking about.
You are now keeping score by shaming or by writing horrible things about these
people or by attacking them or organizing groups of,
of likeminded fuck heads to go out and attack these people and you're just
creating a competitive,
sort of a antagonistic combative environment,
right?
You're not doing any good.
You might feel better yourself.
Like we,
yeah,
we went out there and got them but,
but you know like,
and let's bring that full circle.
You were talking about bullying before and we can see that starting at a
playground,
you can actually see that wiring in kid,
they're keeping score of toughness at that point and that becomes part of the
thing that they're keeping score.
But then you look at the real masters,
like many of these fighters that we know and you transcend at a certain point,
the masters transcend the idea of keeping score and they just are,
you know,
like the baddest fighters are just tough.
They don't have to show it.
They don't have them to bow up to somebody or bully anybody.
Cain Velasquez,
perfect example.
Exactly.
He'd ever seen her leave and makeup mean face.
It doesn't have to beat the shit out of everybody.
No mean face.
He's not keeping score on toughness anymore.
The game,
he's transcended the game.
And same with anybody in these,
in the mortalities sphere,
if they're attacking people and it's just showing their,
you know,
kind of amateur nature in that game,
in this kind of lack of mastery of that.
Because the true spiritual masters,
those people who really are the most morally impeccable people,
they're not doing that shit.
They've tent,
they've transcended keeping score people healthy relationship in business.
You know,
you see that like Elon Musk giving away all his patents and things.
I don't know him personally,
I can't vouch that he's perfect,
but you start to see principals of,
Hey,
let's just share.
There's enough to go around and they've transcended this score keeping
mentality.
And that's true mastery.
You know,
when you get to that level rather than this really poor rural kind of game of
such return aligned at that point,
you,
you now like the internal scorekeeper.
I don't,
I'm not looking at you to get my own validation.
So I don't need to aggressively try and sell my approach.
I don't need to prove to you that I'm right and then get your feedback.
So I feel better about myself.
Know essentially we internalize over time.
Some people have it kind of out the gate because of good parenting or good
genetics are a whole host of other things.
Some people develop it over time through on personal mastery,
be able to like walk in the world with that self confidence that you you,
you were already like you used the word a lot,
which I appreciate,
which is impeccability.
We're already walking and impeccable life.
We're already aligned with everything that we feel is important for us to do in
the world.
We've internalized that self referencing ability to be content,
whether it's content in the tank or content across the the discussion platform.
I think you have to have varying disciplines in your life as well.
I don't think concentrating on one thing for any long period of time,
although I've done it many times in my life.
I don't think it's ultimately healthy.
I think it's,
it's very good short term to achieve great success in a small amount of time or
a relatively small amount of time.
But I think that ultimately that is one of the,
that can trip you up if your whole world say,
you know,
back to what we're saying here,
like a computer company.
If you own a computer company,
if your whole world is that computer company,
I think that's ultimately very unhealthy.
But if you have this computer company and then you start getting into Jujitsu,
like you might,
we might relax a little bit about the fucking computer company.
I realize like,
oh,
okay.
Like there's a lot of different things I can kind of like put this energy
towards and some of them actually enhance my human potential.
They actually develop me as a human being and not getting so caught up in those
numbers.
Like there's a lot of people that will look at things.
This is a really common thing to say like,
uh,
like you'll see a guy like bill gates,
man,
if I had his money,
I wouldn't fucking work at all.
Yeah.
That's why you'll never have his money.
He just like the type of guy that becomes a bill.
Gates is a fucking obsessed dude.
You,
you,
you have to have this insane mindset towards progress and towards continuing to
move the number,
come,
continuing to move that needle.
And that's the only way you get to develop a company like Microsoft.
You have to hire like minded folks and you have to all compete together as a
team to try to achieve world dominance.
And something is lucrative as the computer market.
It's the only way you,
you,
you don't get there by being like some casual dude who like,
you know,
likes to take a lot of time off and work on myself and you know,
no,
you know,
you get up Bill Gates body,
he look all goofy as fuck.
You know,
that dude doesn't do dead lifts.
Look at Bill Gates.
Bill Gates has no submission defense,
but take us back.
He just immediately taps why?
Cause he's put all of his energy into creating this Microsoft monolithic empire.
That's is unstoppable at this point.
And it's probably,
I mean it's sort of semiretired now,
but I think a lot of that has to do with age,
you know,
and once you got 90 fucking billion dollars in the bank,
they're also comes to this point where like I don't,
I can't even spend this.
Like I literally can't spend this.
So I think that having varying disciplines,
like I do a lot of different things and I didn't know ways,
but in doing a lot of different things,
doing martial arts and playing pool and then doing a meditation and getting the
tank and doing standup comedy and doing podcasts and fight commentary and all
these various things,
none of those things have a lot of weight.
To me,
they're all very significant and important.
But if one of them went away,
I'd be fine.
Like if the UFC calls me up today and said,
hey,
you can't do the UFC anymore,
I'd be like,
well I had a great time.
Thanks guys.
Appreciate it.
Take care.
And that would be the,
that would be fine with me.
Like I've got enough other things that I do.
Diversified your portfolio.
Well,
if,
if it was my whole life,
it would be devastating.
But it's never your whole life.
Your life is your life.
And sometimes people forget that your life is your life.
It's this girl,
man,
if she leaves me,
I can't do it,
dude,
you can do it.
Trust me.
The only people who got dumped and moved on,
what,
you're the one person who can't do it.
You get the fuck Outta here,
bitch.
Just go find,
go to match.com.
I guarantee you,
you're going to get laid in a month.
You're going to be so happy or free,
you know,
get on Tinder.
I mean he's like,
these are bad examples,
but swipe right,
swipe right,
but,
but involve yourself in more than one thing to versify your life.
You can't,
if your life is completely revolving around one thing,
but then there's other places where that is a bad advice.
Like fighting.
I think like I think you should have some few things that you do outside of
fighting,
but if you're going to engage in something like martial arts,
like the amount of time that you have to do to compete there,
the amount of time that you have to dedicate to it,
it's almost impossible to have any other sort of life.
I think one of the key things is there's the development of skills,
which is important to diversify,
but you're really developing your identity.
And if your sole identity is as a fighter,
what happens when you break your arm or your shoes,
your shoe with,
then all of a sudden you're in this huge depression.
But let's say you're a fighter and you're also part of your identity is,
you know,
maybe you're a family man and you're a good,
you have,
uh,
you're a good father and that becomes part of your identity and you're a good
fighter and you're,
you know,
you'd like to write or you like to paint and then all of a sudden you have
multiple things.
So if one thing leaves,
then you have many other parts that really make your life,
give it purpose,
given meaning.
And I think the problem can be inherent in any of these things.
Like you see parents whose soul life is the parenthood process,
their identity is their kid's success,
their identity,
his father of so,
so mother of so and so.
And so that becomes an issue as well.
So diversifying your identity to the point where yeah,
all of these are just things,
but it's really you yourself,
that you're,
you know,
this being on this planet,
that doesn't need attachment to actually anything at all.
They're just all parts of your life.
Things that you enjoy,
you know,
that's the state of invulnerability where they can take away any one thing.
Even your own physical,
like physical ability.
It's something that's very good to cultivate them all about it.
But if you have your sole identity wrapped up in that and you get in some kind
of accident,
you know you're going to have a fucking hell of a time.
Because if all you look at yourself is your physical ability and you haven't
cultivated anything else,
your spiritual ability or your emotional connection to other people or these
other things,
it's you putting all your eggs in one basket.
It's a dangerous place to be because the universe loves to go around and play.
Gotcha.
On any type of thing that we have too much attachment to.
It's crazy how that's such a catch 22 it's like in order to achieve great
success,
you have to,
it has to literally become your world.
You have to be obsessed with it.
You have to like everything that I've ever done that I've got really good at,
I became completely obsessed with it.
[inaudible] it was living,
eating and breathing it.
Like I had no identity other than that.
But that doesn't bounce you out as a human being.
It's almost like you're,
you go through the sprints and then you know when you get out of the spring like
I'm going to stop here for a second.
I can't keep doing this anymore.
And then you know,
you almost have to get through that in order to realize that there does need to
be some sort of diversification and your interests.
Miyamoto Musashi wrote about that and the book of five rings.
One of the things that he,
he talked about that was really important was that a great fighter,
a Great Samurai,
had to also be a great philosopher,
had to also be a great artist,
had also like there was a balance that had to be achieved where there was never
any eh,
ridiculous anger.
There was no outburst,
no stupidity,
there's no foolhardiness and this was all balanced.
There was this symbiotic relationship that you had to all of your emotions and
all of your fears and all of your ideas and all of your expression and your art
was also you're killing and all of those things move together and that without
that balance you,
you would miss.
Something would go wrong.
You would fail to see it in front of you.
You would fail to Perry,
you'd fail to counter and you would die on the battlefield.
If your identity is too wrapped up in one thing,
you will crave the success in a way in which you need it because you need that
to support you in that.
And the second that you need something or crave something,
it belies a certain underlying fear that you're not going to get that.
And the minute you have fear that you're not going to get it,
you're not going to be performing at your best ability.
You know?
So,
you know,
I heard a great poker player who told me that his mentor who had won some world
series of poker said,
you know,
you'll win the world series of poker when it isn't a big deal if you win the
world series of poker.
Like you've just gotten to the point where you've mastered that art to such a
degree that you don't crave that to,
to form your identity.
You're not afraid of not getting that.
It's just like,
yeah,
this is what I do.
I'm one of the best in the world and this is what's going to happen.
You know when,
when it's,
yeah,
you can be stoked,
but it's not this deep need because anytime you need something,
whether it's a girlfriend,
whether it's something in your career,
you really need it to the point where if you don't get it,
you think you're going to freak out.
You're going to be too afraid to actually get it.
I mean,
this is also that very important transition for when you actually do achieve
that thing.
Now what?
Right.
Look at a guy like Mike Tyson in his prime.
I mean he was the epitome of dedication.
You know,
I remember watching this video of Mike Tyson describing his early morning runs
that he could wake up later and Ron,
but he got a little bit of an edge knowing that as he was running his opponent
was sleeping,
you know,
and that he would work out.
I mean,
he was an impeccable condition when he was being trained by custom model.
He was,
he was living the complete total existence of a man.
Hell bent on becoming the world champion.
And then once it became the world champion,
then he's buying tigers and smacking bitches and punching people in Bodega is,
and you just out of his fucking mind,
right?
Because he'd achieved this unstoppable,
this,
this status,
this peak of existence that he had belonged for forever.
But then where are the goals now?
What every,
every fight is a 32nd assault.
You know,
I mean those,
those,
those eighties fights with Tyson where he would just show up and look at people
and they would melt the Bruce Seldon fights where,
you know,
he got dropped from a left hook,
didn't even connect like just the ghost.
It was like,
she,
like
when you,
I think there's a lack of a challenge,
then there's a lack of a goal.
There's no more mountain.
So now it's just chaos and cocaine and women and,
and,
and then eventually the wheels fall off.
The lack of balance.
Yeah.
I mean that's the,
you know,
that is the warrior poet concept that we lost somewhere along the way.
We started celebrating it.
People in the extremes,
you know,
and,
and you celebrate that with extreme amount of money to,
you know,
in which is the allure,
like a laser.
Someone who can be really good at one thing can achieve a lot of financial
success,
but they're not generally going to achieve happiness.
But that's not what's celebrated or measured,
you know?
But that used to be the norm.
You know,
I think I've talked about it on,
on here before like that in ancient Greece and Rome in ancient Japan.
And this idea of the Bushido in this,
this way of cultivating many different skills and talents,
calligraphy along with swordsmanship philosophy along with holding the shield
line,
you know,
all of these different things that's been kind of lost a little bit along the
way.
And I think that's a huge part of bringing back and embrace of what it is to be
a man and for,
for women,
you know,
what it is to be a woman holding their own,
special magic in whatever field it is.
Not just attractiveness,
not just how good you look,
not just how sexy you are,
but what other things that you can cultivate.
You know,
what emotional intelligence,
what other skills,
maybe it is on the more masculine side,
whatever.
But rounding out the spectrum of everybody I think will really yield much,
much more positive results because again,
going back to this,
these tragedies you see with bullying and all the suicides so much as attached
to their identity is attached to attractiveness and social status on these,
on these networks where if they were a great poet or a great painter,
a great basketball player,
a great soccer player,
you know,
there would be one element of truth that they could always rely on even when the
world seemed to take away that,
and let's say they were good at multiple things.
Let's say they were good at caring for an animal and good at and good at soccer
and good at,
you know,
writing and they were attractive.
All right,
will you take away that one finger of attractiveness?
Cool.
They still got these multiple areas,
so I think that's a key thing.
You know,
if you look at developmentally ideas to instill in young people is having
multiple things that they can draw steam from when everything looks like it's
collapsing and say,
ah,
I can sort it out.
You know?
I think counterintuitively also the idea that bullying is just a natural part
of,
of people growing up.
I think it's a natural part of people growing up that never learned how to
fight.
You know,
where you see very little bullying or very little tolerance of bullying martial
arts schools.
It is very,
it is looked at as one of the worst character traits,
a true martial artists.
A true master can have.
You know,
like one of the easiest things you could do,
like say if you want to do Jujitsu,
if you want to roll with a guy like Marcello Garcia,
you're,
you're not going to get hurt.
You're just not gonna.
He's not gonna hurt you.
He'll tap you.
You will be forced into positions we have to tap out.
But that's not hurting you.
That's,
he's going to beat you at the game of Jujitsu.
But as far as like harm you,
he's not going to harm you.
And as far as the way he treats you,
he's the kindest,
sweetest guy ever.
And one of the reasons why is because he is a true master at killing people with
his bare hands,
without actually harming people.
It seems contradictory.
I think the best way to stop bullying in school would be to make martial arts
available to everyone and to,
to explain to them this isn't about becoming a tough guy.
It's about overcoming your own self,
overcoming your own insecurities,
your own ego,
which is a battle that is constant.
It's like is that expression about,
um,
there's an expression about inspiration is a,
that inspiration is like bathing.
Uh,
it works but it works for short periods of time.
That's why we recommend it daily.
You know,
like you can't just base once a year and go,
what the fuck a dude booth when my dirty,
you know,
I mean it's the same thing with developing your mind,
controlling your ego,
um,
uh,
controlling your fears,
Re re reassuring your anxieties and assessing the objective view or assessing an
objective view of,
of your life and your,
your,
your perspective on the world.
And I think it's very difficult to do without some discipline,
without some sort of task oriented discipline.
And in my opinion,
one of the best ones is martial arts.
And it's one of the best ones for dealing with interpersonal conflict because we
want to pretend that no one's going to fight.
We want to like,
well we don't want bullying,
we don't want fighting.
We don't want that in this school.
Well you have it.
Okay,
you have it and you don't why you have it.
One of the reasons why have it,
you're not addressing the underlying problems.
So what it means to be a person,
especially what it means to be a developing man growing up and having all these
thousands of years of instincts and DNA ingrained in your,
your,
your biological system.
And then you're supposed to just ignore them.
And you wonder why men gravitate towards to toxic masculinity,
like,
you know,
video games and,
and fucking watching the Avengers they,
so it's not toxic.
It's a part of being a human,
like a part of being a human.
The reason why we got here in 2015 it's not because everybody did yoga and a
Tofu.
It's because there were fucking warriors and they fought off other warriors
because we used to be rampaging tribes of people.
Okay.
And we evolve past that over millions of years to get to where we are now.
But it's foolish to pretend that we're done.
It's fucking foolish.
It's foolish to,
but why not?
So Harry,
what is that?
That's monkey DNA,
man.
I'm still fucking animal.
There's animal in us.
We're not these aliens with these large gray heads and,
and like frail bodies and we move things around with telepathy.
Maybe that's in our future,
we're not there yet.
And to pretend that we're there now is ignoring our biological system and that's
ensuring they're going to have these same issues over and over and over again.
I think that some of the nicest people I've ever met have been martial artists,
and I really believe that if we taught that in school from the time when
children were little,
so it's not some scary freaky thing that you have to enter into as an adult,
but it's a part of a normal everyday management of life program.
I think we would be a lot better off,
a lot better off.
He would alleviate a lot of that anxiety of physical altercation to,
it wouldn't be some threat that everybody's holding over everybody's head to,
you know,
it'd be much easier existence,
I think.
I think you make a perfect point there because it's not in d anytime he tried to
deny these natural instincts that you have,
you're going to have a problem.
So,
and then the other aspect is,
okay,
let's placate them.
All right,
well that kind of works a little bit,
but really what we should do is celebrate them and allow them to channel in
positive ways.
You know,
celebrate that urge to use your body in these strong physical,
you know,
forums and martial arts is a great way to channel that Jujitsu,
particularly because with Jujitsu you can go 100% against somebody and not
typically not hurt them.
You know,
it's this real contest.
Wrestling was a way that a lot of people did that for thousands of years as
well.
Developing different wrestling styles.
You'll see it in Africa,
that Greco Roman style sumo,
whatever.
It's a way that people can exert force upon each other safely and celebrate the
art form of that.
Same with sexuality and I think there's a huge problem with that.
People just deny the fact that we're sexual beings and we better not teach sex
ed or the kids might have sex.
What the fuck are you talking about?
Countries and cultures where they teach sex ed younger,
they have lower teen pregnancy rates,
right?
And they have actually more pro social sexual engagements because people are
talking about it.
She could say the same thing about the psychedelic experience like the island,
which is a crowd favorite of ours by Aldous Huxley.
He talks about the rights of passage ceremonies.
That includes Moke,
Hsa medicine,
which is probably siliciden that is done in the group setting for kids as a
rights of passage to going into their adulthood that supported and stewarded by
those that have already gone through it.
So like your Dojo master,
working with people in the early stages of martial arts training or somebody
that's medicine positive and experienced working with kids going into
psychedelic altered states of consciousness to be able to expand their
worldview.
So all these things were,
were we repressed information,
sexuality,
angiogenics,
physical engagement.
Anytime we were oppressing those things,
they're going to come out anyway.
And they usually come out in these distorted destructive ways.
Yeah,
so set the bar with really good practices and all of these areas,
sexuality,
physicality and spirituality.
Like,
really,
if you're nurturing somebody young,
you got to hit those areas in a really conscious way and not be scared of him.
That's,
that is what we are.
Like you said,
we got fucking hair on our bodies.
Like let's enjoy that.
It's not going to last forever.
It's a cool time.
Let's really enjoy this period.
Whatever comes next comes next.
But celebrate that in a positive way.
You know,
teach kids,
not just this is what to do.
Always wear a condom,
blah,
all of that.
But it'd be like,
all right,
this is what to do if you think you're about to come and you really should,
would rather hold off a little longer.
Like,
you know,
not just think about baseball,
but there's like tantric practices that can help you,
like different breathing techniques.
I can put that like actionable information.
So kids are like,
okay,
I can calm down a little bit in this situation and maybe this can be,
instead of this short,
violent experience that leaves everybody feeling like,
ah,
what was that?
You know,
teach them how to make it a positive experience so they don't get all this
baggage attached to these sexual encounters.
Cause I've,
I've encountered that a lot.
People who've had really caustic and damaging sexual encounters with people
where it's like so much tension built up,
so much ignorance around it and then something happens and it's just short and
violent and it's terrible.
It's like Ah,
that was an awful traumatic experience where you could just be like,
look,
we're all going to have sex.
It's cool.
Here's some techniques.
This is what's pleasurable.
This is what's respectful,
this is what safe.
These are some techniques that can help out and celebrate that.
Just the same as you would teach martial arts.
Just the same as you would steward people through true experiential spirituality
where they get in touch with that other thing either inside themselves or in the
other,
you know,
astral in the,
in the light world,
whatever you want to say,
you know,
steward them in positive ways through those main categories and it's a different
fucking world at that point.
There's also a lot of confusing and conflicting signals that are out there.
People expressing themselves in ways that aren't necessarily honest,
but in instead they're trying to calm their own anxieties or distort the,
distort other people's perceptions of reality to,
to match up with the way they identify themselves.
And when you see this all the time with a homophobic people who will talk very
horribly about gay sex,
and then you find out that they're actually gay,
I mean this is,
it's,
it's so common like this mixed signal,
this wire,
this confusion going on.
People that uh,
don't
feel sexually attractive,
don't feel awkward or feel awkward rather,
and don't feel like they're there.
They want to diffuse or deny or,
or demean the idea of the importance of sexual contact.
Like I read this piece the other day where someone was saying that there is no
such thing as the urge for sex.
I,
there is,
there's no set,
there's no sex drive.
She actually said this.
They were saying there is no sex drive.
There's a drive to eat,
there's a drive to salute.
You have dropped.
But if you don't have sex,
you are fine and I'm like,
you're out of your fucking mind.
Like what are you talking about?
How do you think they've got to be 7 billion people in the world?
We all just decided to fuck.
Let me just slow.
Let's try this.
No,
there's a god damn crazy drive.
There's numerous examples through every species of people risking their animals,
risking their life to have sex.
Sure.
You know,
why do these,
why do these animals in the wild?
Why do they fight to the death for like the seventh cow in the Harem or like,
like you don't do that because you're just trying to survive.
It's because there's an instinct to reproduce.
It's probably as strong as the instinct to survive and in some cases superseding
it.
How about elk?
They grow trees out of their fucking head so they could smash these trees and to
other elk.
They stab each other.
These trees have pointy ends.
They don't grow blunt.
They have fucking points on the end.
And if you ever seen elk fight,
they have holes all over their chest and their cape all over their neck area
where they jam their fucking,
these swords that grow every year at their head.
When it's time to fuck,
when it's time,
their urge is so strong that their body grows swords out of their fucking head.
And then when they're done fucking they drop off,
they fall off.
I mean,
it's insane to think that there's not a sex drive.
It's insane.
But this was a whole article by some chubby dummy that has shitty hormone
balance,
never goes jogging,
I'm sure,
and just feels completely unattractive sexually.
So they're in denial about the urge and the need and whether or not it's a core
component of life because it's so waited because he use sex to sell Jaguars and
lipstick and fucking buildings and you know,
there's always a woman with her legs and long land,
a man with abs and a fucking Calvin Klein commercial and all this sex,
sex,
sex.
You know,
there's people that just feel like I'm out of that game.
Like that game does not apply to me.
I'm here eating donuts.
My,
my,
my gut looks like a fucking beanbag chair and I'm not that guy or I'm not that
girl.
And so they deny the existence of it.
And if you,
uh,
if you show a picture of yourself looking hot,
you're fat shaming,
which is one of my all time favorite of all the retarded social justice warrior
sayings,
fat shaming,
like can't shame you if you're not fat.
How about that?
Well,
the repression creates these other things.
Like the reason why Americans use sex to sell everything is because sex has been
so repressed
that we,
and yes,
we crave it in some crazy,
weird way.
If it was just a healthy relationship with it,
it would be like,
why is the really hot girls selling a cheeseburger?
Right.
It'd be funny and people would laugh at it instead of being like all Paris
Hilton was sauce dripping down her face.
It was amazing.
You know,
way less effective for people to get laid all the time.
Yeah,
for sure.
When people are married and their wives kind of dumpy and they're kind of dumpy
and they just,
no one ever touches them and no one's attracted them.
And then they see some chick with dark red lipstick on and our breasts are
plumped up and she's in some fucking outfit and she's selling Burger King or
something like that.
I like,
oh boy.
You like what?
It just draws you to it because it's unavailable because it's,
it's,
it's just outside of the realm of possibility and your meager existence so they
can,
it's,
it becomes currency becomes like a huge selling point and you look at the amount
of things that we sell with beautiful women.
I mean,
it's staggering if you just did a montage of all the different things that we
try to sell with beautiful scantily clad women.
It's amazing.
I mean,
it's amazing.
It's,
it's a really crazy,
yeah.
I mean in a healthy relationship I suppose it would be like,
you know,
you,
it's not to not celebrate beautiful women.
Beautiful women are inherently going to be something that people are going to
enjoy seeing.
Just like a great,
beautiful bouquet of flowers.
Like you have a beautiful bouquet of flowers on your table.
You know you're going to look at that and you're going to say,
Oh man,
that's beautiful.
That's a beautiful part of the world.
That's a beautiful part of nature that exists and you can appreciate it,
but not using that to manipulate and in some weird way and cause a reaction and
then use that momentum and steer it and turn it.
You know?
That's where it gets weird.
But I think all the,
you know,
all too often people forget that other part,
which is,
yeah,
that is a beautiful part of the world.
It's,
it's beautiful to look at it be beautiful to smell.
It'd be beautiful in a variety of different ways.
We can fully celebrate that,
but just not manipulate that urge into something that's not helpful.
But it's one of those weird things where when things are suppressed,
they gain so much energy and so much power that are almost unavoidable.
I mean this,
this,
this momentum and energy behind them that it like the Catholic priest that is
forced into celibacy and now nobody trusts that fuck cause he's just this,
this just barely hanging on,
clinging,
clinging like a piece of cheesecloth,
holding back the ocean,
you know,
just,
it's not natural.
You know,
it's not normal.
And that's why the,
the image or the depiction of the Catholic priests as being some sex crazed,
pervert,
pedophile,
why it exists,
it's completely,
totally unnatural to repress yourself sexually.
It has nothing to do with homosexuality.
Like people will say,
low Catholic priests are all really gay
and that's why they go into priesthood.
Get Gay and molesting kids are completely unrelated,
right?
That is not what's going on.
What did,
what's going on is these poor fucking people have no sexual outlet.
And that is totally unnatural.
It is the epitome of denying your physical existence is exactly what we're
talking about earlier.
The denial of the,
the uh,
the body as a biological organism that has existed for untold thousands of years
in the exact same state that you find yourself in today.
And that existence is predicated on the need to breed sexual desire.
And the fact that you're buying is making fucking sperm every day of the week.
Okay?
It's just constantly doing it because it doesn't know that you're a priest.
You know,
your body just thinks it's a body.
you,
you have to exist as a human being under the confines of being a human being.
When you deny your humanity because it doesn't fit your idea or your aesthetic
or your,
your,
your ridiculous notions of what you should be.
Well,
you're going to run into problem son.
I mean that's the,
you,
we should all aspire to greater heights.
But in doing so,
you've got to address the reality of what the fuck you are.
That's again,
going back to the definition of consciousness.
Consciousness is fully embodied.
You know,
it is not just sitting on a mountain only accessing your spiritual body.
It's fully embodied.
It's being a human in your body and bringing that home and bringing in the,
the unity of that whole system together.
That's,
you know,
that's what,
what it really boils down to.
That's what's going to lead the happiest,
most fulfilled life.
And make you someone who society can lean on like an anchor that creates these
people that are just the pillars,
the leaders,
the people who can be there when the shit hits the fan.
You know,
I mean,
that's,
that's who everybody should aspire to be.
An embodied being of consciousness,
not just a consciousness being and not just a body.
Bring it all together and there should be a bunch of us around.
So it's normal.
I mean,
I would say us,
like we've got it nailed,
but I mean a bunch of humans that are like that around so that we could all sort
of feed off of each other and imitate our atmosphere in a very positive way.
And I think,
um,
you know,
there's a lot of people running through life that they don't have anyone around
them,
that,
that is living a life that they would aspire to.
And so it's really hard to dream.
It's really hard to picture an ideal existence because your existence is sort
of,
it's modeled out of what you see in your environment,
your environment.
There's a lot of misery and bullshit and,
and just confusion and despair.
It's like that.
Um,
who was the,
the great author that made that quote?
Was it Walden?
I forget.
Thorough.
Uh,
all men leave.
Most men lead lives of silent desperation and that's the,
that's the realities.
Like most
people,
I mean he,
he's a man,
so he wrote about men,
but most people I think live lives of,
of longing for better silent desperation.
Just like,
this is it.
This is,
this is what I'm doing.
Well,
you get shot.
You know,
like you're in your cubicle and you just want to grab that,
that image,
that famous video of a guy who's in his cubicle,
he just starts punching his keyboard and then just smashes his computer monitor
and picks it up and smash it on the ground.
It was all caught by security camera.
Have you ever seen that video?
It embodies cubicle life to me because this guy just hit that point well like
fuck,
smashes the whole thing.
I mean,
it's just so many people are like on that brink just right there.
And so they numb themselves.
They numb themselves with alcohol or medicine x or television or all of these
things to damp in these and make it,
make it possible instead of just really looking at what's the what,
let's go for the fucking win.
Like what's the win?
What's the situation?
Even if it's not normal,
even if it's a little weird,
even if it's on the fringe,
like what's the win for me?
Like,
fuck what everybody else thinks.
You know,
I'm going to forge a new way.
Maybe that is being some crazy ice Fisher in some desolate place,
or maybe it's living in a nonmonogamous community or maybe whatever.
Like what's your win?
Go for the win.
Like don't just accept,
Eh,
okay.
You know,
this was okay.
This,
this lifetime we did all right.
We made it through,
you know,
just go for the fucking win.
Yeah.
It's like hunters Thompson description of how to end life screeching sideways
with the wheels falling off.
Like don't pull in and park at the end of the life like you want your radiator
to be overheating,
engine smoking.
Everything fell apart.
You know,
I know this woman Sue Akins,
uh,
she's on that show life below zero shoes on the podcast.
She's just fucking great,
great character.
She's in her fifties.
She lives 200 miles above the arctic circle on a place called Kavach and a
Alaska and she loves it.
That's her.
That's her reality.
That's a reality for the,
when she went for the win and it's not my,
when it's not your win by win.
Exactly.
So this is not your win,
but it's her when man,
she fucking loves it.
When she talks about it,
she talks about it with like true love.
Like she,
she is enjoying it.
She loved that.
It fits her personality.
It fits her worldview.
She loves it.
She's in the midst of ongoing crowded therapy.
Yeah.
She had just these pretty,
pretty young kids a week.
Cryotherapy though,
you know,
she's not really doing the 250 degrees below zero.
She only gets down to like 90,
but she does it for way longer.
Sure.
So
it's different.
Yeah.
What were some of when you were treating patients in the clinical pathology
thing,
like what were some of the,
the patterns that you saw that were,
you know,
really for some of the real challenges that people face,
like growing up,
you know,
like what were the main themes that were the hardest,
hardest to deal with and bring into a healthy adult?
Why trauma and disconnection?
Disconnection from like what Joe was saying in regards to mentorship and having,
having a big brother or somebody in that role,
did they get aspire to be like that could coach them through challenging
situations and going through trauma because trauma is so rampant and it's also
our,
our representation and our internalization of trauma.
Some people take that on as an identity,
that they've been traumatized or they've been abused and,
and because it's not discussed,
it's in fact shamed.
Um,
it's not really dealt with above board whether it's people being traumatized
sexually because the,
the perpetrator,
the person actually doing the traumatic event,
they weren't integrated in their own sexuality.
So it came out in a perverse way or it was the internalization of something that
seemed mild but because they didn't have the languaging and the opportunity to
connect with somebody that it,
it held and seated over time.
Like if you see animals in the wild,
when they get traumatized,
like if you were driving a car and you hit a deer,
the first thing that deer is going to do when he gets to the side of the road,
it's going to shake it out.
It's going to just move that somatically out of its body because trauma gets
imprinted into the sematic infrastructure like,
but on,
he was talking about into like the Fascia trauma gets fat,
kids gets programmed into the body,
it also gets trauma.
We'll change the genetic expression.
You actually see the DNA genetic code change its expression at the time of
trauma.
And that can be recapitulated transgenerationally.
So from generation to generation to generation,
I can still hold my parents' trauma,
my grandparents,
like an epigenetic phenomenon.
It's a transgenerational epigenetic phenomena.
Right?
So that's so crazy.
It's so crazy.
So we,
we are,
and that's what the native Americans talk about.
Like our,
our actions right now do affect seven generations down the line because it takes
that long to bleed it out of the jeans unless you clear it.
And so trauma has a big hold,
that sense of disconnection because we grew up in these disenfranchised
families.
Like you know,
mom and dad drive in with little Johnny in the back and they hit the garage door
opener,
drive in garage door goes down like little Johnny's getting his social
engagement through computer games and through Twitter and Facebook and texting.
You see kids nowadays texting across from each other.
It's crazy as opposed to having this engagement.
They're texting,
not just kids,
grown adults.
I've,
I,
I can't tell you how many times I've gone to dinner with friends that are in
their thirties and forties and five people at a table and everyone's staring at
their phone,
right?
Right.
So where's that sense of connection?
And that gets recapitulated and it build,
particularly because kids are little sponges and their social middle you is
really developing its foundation when they're really young that way.
So if it starts so young,
then it solidifies over time until there's a massive interjection of some new
kind of thing.
And so it's important for kids to be absorbed in nature.
It's important for them to have like the,
the correct mentioned mentorship about not shaming,
not blaming,
bringing everything up to the surface.
And then the whole way that we work with,
for example,
like the penal system,
the whole judicial system is completely backwards.
We,
we labeled the perpetrator and the victim and then the whole legal system is set
up against that way.
It's right.
That's like warring.
It's not about like,
um,
uh,
it's not about a cooperative model.
It's not about healing the Vick,
the,
the perpetrator.
It's about rescuing the victims so people in that victim mentality.
I'm not even about rescuing the victim,
just getting vindication,
getting revenge,
right?
Like I'm going to get paid for being a victim and that perpetrator's going to go
off somewhere and not get rehabilitated and people don't typically get better in
prison.
And when you look at like the whole downstream effect of that victim hood,
this was really good article by getting the Simon tons,
there were men and wife couple in the 80s they had some of the first early mind
body studies that showed the importance of what you think,
how it affects your body.
They were,
he was an oncologist and she was a research psychologist and there were four
things that that no matter what level of cancer,
like stage or what type of cancer,
there were consistent measures that showed people getting better and people
getting worse.
And one of those the consistently show people getting worse was victim hood.
Like they didn't believe that they had any empowerment to change their
situation.
Also inability to give and receive love,
resentment and low self esteem or self worth.
When you had all four of those you were like,
fuck,
that's so crazy thing.
The connection between the immune system.
Right and your perceptions of the environment,
right?
Your perceptions of the world that you live in.
Right.
And you should just shoot.
We just showed,
you just showed me this morning,
um,
some article and wellbeing.
I think it was um,
the perception,
uh,
they did this really interesting study of housekeepers and housekeepers that
proceed that we're told that the activities that they were engaging with just
cleaning the hotel rooms.
And so they were told whatever they were doing,
cleaning,
fixing things that,
that at the dot they were told that that was healthy.
There was a group that was told that that was good exercise and another group
that wasn't told anything.
And after a period of weeks they did biologic physiologic markers and showed
that the,
the,
the women that had the idea that they were exercising more,
had a less um,
uh,
weight gain.
I should,
their weight started to redistribute,
they had better blood pressure.
And heart rate measures,
their whole physiology shifted because of their belief,
not because they changed their activities at all.
So when you,
when you look at the other side of that equation,
you had certain things that because of the way you thought made the illness
continue to seed that cancer profile,
the two things that consistently help people get better was their faith,
their belief in a reason that this was happening or some,
some level of empowerment that they,
that they could utilize this,
this experience for benefit like the housekeepers and visualization that you
could actually visualize yourself becoming better.
And they've also shown that with kids and kids are extraordinarily good
visualizers when you can,
you know,
kids that are,
maybe it's an oncology department and like one of the pediatric hospitals,
when you can help them visualize their immune system actually working against
the cancer or overcoming something or you can project yourself into the future,
healed happy well and you engage with that and you feel into that and you
project that into the future.
That perspective shifts the physiology,
the psycho neuro immunological triad shifts towards healing just because of the
power of the mind.
That is wild.
There's a placebo effect involved in being a housekeeper.
Totally.
Yup.
Well it wasn't just about being a housekeeper,
it was about being athletically engaged in what they were doing.
Yeah,
they said that they told one group of housekeepers that the,
the exercise they were doing,
Mitt met the surgeon general's quota for a healthy exercise for an individual.
They use big terms like that method shirt and generals quota and then they told
the other people nothing.
And then they watch the difference in the groups between,
and they were all cleaning hotel rooms in the same as randomized and the people
who felt that they were meeting the surgeon general's requirement for exercise
had all of these dramatic improvements in weight loss and all these
physiological markers.
Wow.
I mean it crazy,
crazy.
That's just human beings and our minds are so fucking strange and the power of
the mind is so and then send,
it feels like this has only been really discovered over the last hundred years,
like even remotely and more so now than ever before.
It's like an onion that's continually peeled and like,
no,
I don't think there's a lot of layers here.
Let's keep going and peeling back layer and layer and layer and we're slowly
starting to unveil the power and the properties and and subsequently a
management system for this incredible engine that we have to construct our
environment.
Yet Joe Dispenza just wrote a book,
you're the placebo and he's got all,
he's got the great scientific backwards.
It's called,
you are the Placebo Joe Dispenza.
Yeah.
He has a ton of articles
and then that was,
I think I was talking about on the last name D I s p e n z a and he was the one
who sites all of these examples of these placebo surgeries,
these sham surgeries like arthroscopic knee surgeries that they did where they
did a placebo knee surgery and a real knee surgery and found that the outcomes
were identical and in some cases the people with the placebo knee surgery where
they basically cut the skin and sewed it back up,
they had better outcomes than the people who had actual knee surgery.
Like things that you think should not have a placebo effect.
Like if you're going to have knee surgery is probably pretty important that
you're going to do that.
No,
you can actually cut the skin,
tell somebody,
Yup,
surgery went great and they'll recover better than the people who actually got
the surgery.
In some cases
it wasn't that dude in that video.
What the bleep do we know?
Totally,
unfortunately.
And back then,
you know,
that was kind of like the leading edge to have this whole mind body experience
and it was,
you know,
showed with kind of the meeting of science and metaphysics and
up until that ramp,
the lady came on and then you're like,
wait a minute,
what's your name?
Hold on.
What's going on?
Here you are,
you're a thousand years old.
Okay.
In a thousand year old spirit that is embodied in this woman and you're talking
nonsense.
Everybody else seems to be talking science and you,
you organize this bitch,
you organize this whole thing.
Okay,
what right wasn't that was what the bleep do we know that?
What the bleep do we know was so god damn confusing because there were some
really interesting stuff and there's some really sound science and that.
Yeah.
And there was also some fucking full laming are rocketing horseshit projectile
who are shit right.
It's like you couldn't get away.
Oh,
get out of here.
That's kind of the nature of our world now,
right?
Like the skill of everything is not being able to throw away all apples with
worms.
And I'm still of our world is to be able to cut out worms effectively and then
eat the fucking apple.
Also recognize it in human beings that you maybe like some aspects of them.
Right.
I was having this conversation with a friend of mine about this guy that we know
that is clearly in some ways a weasel and he's just,
he's weasely and he,
he's super ambitious and you can't trust him and he's not,
he's just not cool.
And he had a bunch of like really bad interactions with other people that I know
that came to me independently and said,
look,
this guy's a fucking fraud.
It's guy's a piece of shit.
But I know him to be also a very good dispenser of interesting information when
I communicate with him.
Like he,
he is really good at dispensing this information.
He gathers it,
he's like,
he's dedicated to it and he,
there's a lot of positive qualities,
qualities in that and he actually enjoys it.
He enjoys expressing himself in this way,
but then the,
all the other stuff,
it makes it so hard.
So some people just write them off and I'm like,
I can't ride them off.
I can't write them off.
Totally.
But unfortunately,
he's an exercise is an exercise
in recognizing like what,
how much of these qualities are positive and how much of what he is is just
douche.
I think I've seen that when I've dealt with different shamans and spiritual
teachers,
you know,
where people tend to want to put them on a pedestal as this being,
that's this perfect being,
and then as soon as they see something a little flawed,
they're like,
oh my God,
my my holy savior is,
is not the holy savior.
I think he's like,
no,
he's just not perfect.
Like everybody else.
He's still really good at this and this and just accept him for that and watch
out for this little,
this little shitty part that he's still working on.
Like it's okay.
He's still trying to get laid.
Yeah,
exactly.
Like people,
you know,
especially in that arena,
they demand this,
this level that's just not realistic.
You know?
Like they did demand this intense perfection.
You know,
that was a,
one of the things that people will bring up.
The detractors of turns Mckenna,
they always bring up the fact that he had some holes in his science and there
were some,
some of this stuff was bullshit.
Maybe,
maybe,
but you,
you can't listen to his hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of available hours of
lectures that he had and not be inspired.
If you have any psychedelic curiosity and you listened to this unbelievably free
thinker,
this guy who's just like really willing to put himself out there and some sort
of,
uh,
and you know,
maybe miss the mark occasionally,
but he's shooting a lot of fucking arrows.
Yeah.
You know,
there's even more extreme examples.
Like I've just recently found out what a crazy fuck Carlos Castaneda was.
He was insane.
He was like yelling at people.
He may have even convinced these women who he was dating to at least disappear
when he died.
I don't know.
They might've committed suicide.
Who even knows?
There's a lot of speculation because all the women he was dating disappeared
when he died.
So he was possibly even a bad person,
like straight up.
Not a good person,
but nonetheless,
you know,
I'll put a quote from cass,
Anita out and you know,
people will just all what he was a crazy fuck.
It's like,
yeah,
but this thing makes sense.
This little pit of philosophy,
it still makes sense and it's still valuable.
Even if he was a crazy fucking person,
like be able to cut out the worm and say admit like,
yeah,
that dude was not a fucking good dude,
but he had some ideas that can be valuable when taken and applied and you,
you get to that,
you'll level up way faster because you'll get to keep more gems then than other
people who are just discarding everything.
It's like the jeep Cuando of life.
Yeah.
Absorb what is useful.
Exactly.
Personally had it nailed the perfect.
Yeah.
Perfect.
And do your shadow work.
Yeah.
Shadow work.
Which is oftentimes what happens in the psychedelic experience or even
flotation.
What do you mean by shadow work?
Like,
like recognize within yourself ourselves.
What's behind the curtain?
Like being able to see those aspects of myself that I haven't fully integrated,
fully accepted because it's only my projection and judgment of somebody else.
There's only a reflection of the shadow
material that I haven't integrated myself.
And usually it's those things that I,
I project onto others that I'm so emotionally connected to are people that
really pissed me off in a particular way that's related to the,
my own shadow work in that,
in that other side of the coin,
right.
That I haven't looked at yet.
The person saying there's no such thing as a sex drive.
Yeah.
Look at her shadow work.
What's their,
what's buying or his,
I don't remember it as a man or a woman,
but either way,
no one's fucking are right.
No one wants to,
you know,
I'll tell you who doesn't talk about that Jennifer Lopez,
that bitch knows is the sex drive.
She's built an empire off of it.
Right.
Um,
let's,
let's end this pitch.
This is a lot of fun to it.
Thank you.
You got a lot of fun.
Then Greg,
can we conversation and I'm so to get in touch with you,
your Twitter is at Dr Dan Engle,
Dr Dan,
angle,
right?
Yup.
Yeah.
Dr D,
a n e n,
g.
L.
E.
And of course a Aubrey.
Marcus is Aubrey Marcus,
uh,
on Twitter,
and uh,
anything else to say?
Anybody,
anything to promote anybody,
anything about a man,
a lot of cool stuff going on,
but we'll all follow us on the social channels.
Will point the finger at the moon.
Yeah.
Cool Shit.
Remember to,
don't concentrate only on the finger.
Cause then you will miss,
I forget the quote Bruce Lee.
All the heavenly growing that lies beyond Dan and go thank you very much sir.
Yeah,
shit it good time.
See you soon.
Bye.
Okay.